bande de parole s'il y en ad'autres
merci de me le dire maintenant pour la
bonne organisation de nos travaux il ya
déjà une dizaine de demandes
et en premier madame jasmin
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre au cours de ces cinq dernières
années j'ai posé plusieurs questions
écrites enregistrées au sénat votre
gouvernement n'a pas daigné répondre à
certaines qui était relative justement
pouvoir d'achat les ultramarins beaucoup
de la question sans réponse qui sont
hâtés la caducité ici au sénat alors je
croyais en un espoir lorsque j'ai vu
qu'il y avait cette proposition de loi
est malheureusement la plupart des
amendements que j'ai posé son cas du son
il recevra pardon à 6,45 antilles 40
alors quand est ce que j'aurai des
réponses concrètes aux questions qui
nous préoccupent
concernant l'application des lois de mer
concernant les prix concernant le
transport maritime concernant tout ce
qui contribue à augmenter à mu ivement
les prix dans les outre-mers merci
merci monsieur le président caennais
le président mes chers collègues
monsieur ministre donc nous voici réunis
pour examiner le fameux article 1 de ce
projet de loi qui est la traduction
législative de la fameuse prime dite
macron cette prime monsieur le ministre
si je vous pensais naïf pourrait être
qualifié de fausse bonne idée mais vous
n'êtes pas naïf je crois au contraire
que ce dispositif est la traduction
concrète de l'idéologie néolibérale qui
vous anime toujours néfaste pour les
salariés toujours profitable pour le
patronat sous couvert d'une augmentation
de pouvoir d'achat d'une partie des
français vous mettez en place une
incitation à ne pas augmenter les
salaires et vous accélérez la
fragilisation déjà bien entamée sous le
précédent quinquennat de notre système
de protection sociale
je m'explique un employeur qui a le
choix entre augmenter les salaires ont
versé une prime défiscalisées et sans
cotisations sociales choisira la moins
coûteuse et la moins pérennes vous créez
donc un effet d'aubaine qui ne profitera
pas aux salariés mais il n'ya pas que
cela avec ce dispositif vous dit une
chose le travail coûte trop cher
car la protection sociale des français
coûte trop cher la défiscalisation et la
désocialisation des primes n'auront
qu'un effet limité sur un temps très
court pour les français en revanche
l'effet sur le long terme sur les
finances publiques est bien réelle quand
on enlève les cotisations sociales et
cantons l'ont dit fiscalise on prive de
recettes la protection sociale et le
budget de l'état venant d'un
gouvernement qui veut renflouer les
caisses en réduisant les droits des
chômeurs et en augmentant le 3 ans les
cotisations pour obtenir des droits à la
retraite
c'est indigne monsieur du soft vous
organisez donc la casse du système pour
constater à terme qui ne marche plus
vous êtes de fait les fossoyeurs des
jours heureux du conseil national de la
résistance
encore une fois je vous demande
d'organiser une conférence salariale à
la rentrée chaque français doit vivre
dignement du fruit de son travail tout
le reste n'est que tromperie cynique
prenez garde prenez garde à ce
ruissellement qui prend source dans la
colère sociale des français qui se
traduira peut-être à la rentrée voilà le
risque vous nous faite collectivement
prendre dans ce pays
merci madame benbassa
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le texte
que nous commençons à discuter messieurs
le devant de la salle un fait
indiscutable pour beaucoup de nos
concitoyens
le travail ne paie pas on ne vit pas
avec un smic on survit avec l'explosion
de l'implant sion on survit mais encore
plus difficilement il est donc urgent de
mettre en place des mesures afin de
contenir les effets de l'augmentation
des prix sur les classes moyennes et les
plus précaires c'est très précisément ce
que ne fait pas ce qu'est ce en
proposant des dispositions de coulter et
aux effets incertains concernant le
présent article étude d'impact réalisée
par l'assemblée nationale estime
probable qu'un plus grand nombre de
salariés soient concernés par cette
prime je le rappel seuls 6 millions de
salariés sur un total de 25 millions
avaient pu profiter des anciennes
versions de cette prime pour des
montants très éloignés des plafonds
autorisés combien de nouveaux salariés
pourront prétendre à cette nouvelle
prime trop peu c'est une certitude la
solution à la crise inflationniste n'est
pas dans ce tête seule une véritable
politique de revalorisation des salaires
permettrait à de nombreux français de
vivre de leur travail dignement je suis
également décontenancé face à
l'exonération de cotisations pour cette
prime pour les groupes ayant réalisé des
profits records lors de l'épidémie de
l'aco vide ou ayant des filiales
installées dans des paradis fiscaux par
exemple bénéfices records pour total
avec 5,7 milliards de dollars au premier
trimestre 2001 22 ce n'est pas ce n'est
pas la ristourne sur la sur l'essence
qui va appauvrir total l'exécutif doit
prendre la pleine mesure de ce qui se
joue en ce moment au risque de connaître
une révolte sociale bien plus virulente
que celle du président précédent
quinquennat je remercie la parole est à
mme adama bourse au poly
merci monsieur le président donc
l'article 1er de la loi a le mérite de
la clarification sur nos différences
entre nos projets politiques nous venons
encore de le voir un
puisque vous refusez évidemment que les
salariés 1 puisse gagner 1500 euros pour
le gouvernement et pour l'aller droite
finalement le partage de la valeur
consiste en deux choses inciter les
employeurs à verser des primes et
faciliter la mise en place de
l'intéressement en entreprise pour les
salariés qui n'arrivent pas à boucler
leurs fins de mois le versement d'une
prime peut apparaître évidemment comme
une bonne nouvelle mais si aujourd'hui
une prime met du beurre comme on dit
chez nous dans les épinards demain ces
primes seront pas prises en compte pour
le calcul des pensions de retraite c'est
pourquoi nous sommes autant attaché à
l'augmentation des salaires plutôt qu'au
versement des primes d'autant que ces
primes sont exonérés de cotisations
sociales pour les employeurs ce qui va
évidemment aggravé les comptes de la
sécurité sociale
même si l'état compense décide de
compenser ce sont près de 600 millions
d'euros en moins pour nos services
publics nos écoles donc nous disons
attention à l'effet boomerang
d'ailleurs avec ces dispositifs le
gouvernement a réussi à se mettre à dos
ses propres supporters dans une tribune
publiée le 23 juillet dans le journal du
dimanche l'institut montaigne à
critiquer vos primes est appelée à
revaloriser l'intéressement et la
participation en entreprise heureusement
les droits de sénateur les droits de
sénatoriales sont intervenus en
commission contre la canade
cannibalisation de l'intéressement et la
participation
la prima kron a bénéficié à 5 millions
de salariés en 2021 et 2022 pour un
montant moyen de
545 euros ce n'est donc pas la peine de
donner l'illusion salariés qu'ils auront
six mille euros de prime c'est de la
vaste blague
merci la parole est à madame ferrer
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues dans ce
projet de loi tout est trompeur à
l'image de son titre sur la trentaine
d'articles que compte ce texte moins de
la moitié portent réellement sur le
pouvoir d'achat ceci alors que sur une
année le fioul le gaz les carburants et
les achats en grande surface ont vu leur
prix augmenter
ces derniers mois par tous les conflits
sociaux se sont multipliées afin
d'obtenir des revalorisations salariales
au moins à la hauteur du taux
d'inflation inflation qui sera encore
plus élevée à la rentrée et vous le
savez à cela que répond le gouvernement
cheikh défiscalisation des primes
versées au bon vouloir de l'employeur
absence de cotisations sociales et son
indexation des prestations sociales des
bénéficiaires pour donner l'impression
d'agir on est pourtant très loin du
compte et face à l'urgence une
succession de mesures ponctuelles est
majoritairement financée par l'état ne
peut en aucun cas être une réponse
suffisante nulle part de traces de
partage de la richesse ni même du fameux
ruissellement le cac 40 ayant dégagé
près de 160 milliards d'euros de
bénéfices en 2021 et verser près d'eux
60 milliards d'euros de dividendes il
est regrettable fort regrettable que la
question de l'augmentation des salaires
soient constamment éludée comment
justifier que les salariés en
particulier ceux au smic ou juste
au-dessus s'appauvrissent d'année en
année comment justifier que le
gouvernement refuse d'appeler à la
solidarité nationale de tous celles et
ceux qui se sont le plus enrichi au
cours des derniers mois madame la
première ministre elisabeth bornes nous
avait indiqué que les organisations
syndicales et patronales trouverez en
elle je cite une interlocutrice franches
constructives et déterminé mais que
demande tous les syndicats aujourd'hui
ils demandent l'ouverture de discussions
sur les salaires et quel compromis bâti
de gouvernement avec eux aucun la prise
en charge de mesure de pouvoir d'achat
est aussi de la responsabilité des
employeurs cela doit se traduire par une
augmentation des salaires il serait
grand temps que le gouvernement
l'entende merci la parole est à madame
lubin
merci monsieur le président pour la
deuxième fois en quelques minutes il me
plaît de rappeler ce qu'a dit le
ministre le maire ce matin savoir que la
la le ski ce qui importait c'était la
valorisation du travail mais je pense
que nous n'avons pas tout à fait la même
conception de ce qu'est la valorisation
du travail puisque pour le gouvernement
elle passe essentiellement par des
primes dont nous savons dont nous
connaissons le caractère extrêmement
discrétionnaire et nous savons aussi
les faits le prouvent les chiffres le
prouvent depuis 2019 ce que finalement
peu de salariés trop peu de salariés ont
bénéficié de ces primes et d'ailleurs il
est fort intéressant de regarder qui en
a bénéficié et quelles sont les
entreprises qui les versent se sont
forcément les entreprises les plus
grandes entreprises et celles qui
peuvent dégager le plus de moyens pour
donner ses primes et donc elles vont
essentiellement aux salariés qui ont
déjà les salaires les les plus
importants ensuite je voudrais insister
sur le la trempe peu ri parce qu'il
s'agit bien d'une tromperie sur le
relèvement de la prime s'est tu c'est
une colle on dira c'est un effet de
langage que vous faites là parce que
relever la prime le le plafond à 6000
euros ça ne veut absolument pas dire
relever le montant de la prime et nous
savons très bien puisque la moyenne des
primes versées jusqu'à maintenant ces
500 euros à peu près nous savons très
bien que ça n'ira guère au delà donc
tout ça ce sont des effets de langage
voir
des vins en tout cas pour ce que je
considère être de la tromperie et enfin
la désocialisation ça c'est votre maître
mot à vous écouter les personnes qui
perçoivent des petits salaires ne
pourraient voir leur rémunération
augmenter qu'à la condition de ne plus
s'acquitter de cotisations sociales mais
en fait c'est oublier que ces
cotisations c'est du salaire différé est
désocialisée ces primes ça revient à
spolier les salariés à qui on expliquera
après que l'on n'a pas les moyens
finalement et qu'ils doivent faire des
sacrifices sur leur propre protection
sociale merci merci madame lubin la
parole est à madame conway mouret
aujourd'hui le projet de loi portant sur
les mesures d'urgence pour la protection
du pouvoir d'achat des françaises et des
français 3 million et demi d'entre eux
sont les grands oubliés de ce texte
celles et ceux qui résident à l'étranger
en la crise sanitaire engendré une crise
économique dont les effets dévastateurs
sont durables et se font toujours sentir
certains secteurs tels que celui du
tourisme dans lesquelles exercent ce
nombre de nos compatriotes à l'étranger
mais il est également les artisans les
petits entrepreneurs continuent à subir
le contrecoup des confinement et de la
fermeture des frontières alors que les
entreprises implantées sur le territoire
national ont bénéficié d'un soutien
exceptionnel salle implantées à
l'étranger n'ont pas été intégrée au
périmètre du plan de relance ceux de
tous les acteurs économiques ont
regretté et nous l'avons d'ailleurs
exprimé dans cet hémicycle en adoptant
l'année dernière au sénat une
proposition de loi présentée par notre
ancien collègue jacky d'euromédis contre
l'avis de votre gouvernement les
conseillers du commerce extérieur ainsi
que le réseau des chambres de commerce
et d'industrie à l'étranger ont
également créé une structure et feu
international afin de soutenir les
entreprises françaises à l'étranger qui
travaillent la marque france structure
qui mériterait tout notre soutien par
ailleurs le secours occasion occasion
occasionnels j'arriverai de solidarité
mises en place par le ministère de
l'europe et des affaires étrangers en
avril 2020 en faveur de nos compatriotes
et a subi une diminution substantielle
de leurs revenus à cause de la pandémie
prendra fin le 31 août prochain à cela
s'ajoute la flambée des prix notamment
de l'énergie des denrées alimentaires
dont aucun continent est épargnée si
tepco envisage une revalorisation de 4%
les prestations sociales et des pensions
de retraite rien n'est prévu pour local
compatriotes établis hors de france
monsieur le ministre sid les mesures
d'urgence que vous nous soumettez ne
prennent pas en compte les français de
l'étranger le projet de loi de finances
rectificatif à venir sera l'occasion de
le faire et j'espère sincèrement que
vous ne les oublierai pas en donnant un
avis favorable aux amendements que nous
vous présenterons vous remercie mr c'est
la parole est à monsieur cozic merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre ces cinq dernières années le
gouvernement a considéré que la lutte
contre la pauvreté passer avant tout par
le renforcement des incitations à
travailler sur le fond je ne peux
qu'acquiescer mais c'est sur la forme
que nos chemins divergent car pour y
parvenir vous misez systématiquement sur
des dispositifs qui ne touche pas aux
salaires et cela n'est pas nouveau vous
avez ainsi inciter les entreprises à
verser des primes exceptionnelles en
2018 2020 ou à développer la part
variable des salaires par le biais des
dispositifs que son l'intéressement ou
la participation
dispositif qui ont été renforcées par la
loi pacte de 2019 je le rappelle ces
dispositifs sont en partie désocialisés
et défiscalisées en ce sens qu'ils
visent à complémenter le salaire mais en
aucun cas s'y substituer de plus le
gouvernement a aussi choisi d'augmenter
la prime d'activité qui je le rappelle
est une aide sociale versées par l'état
aux travailleurs modestes force est de
constater que par ce modus operandi
l'argent public vient substituer des
revenus à des salaires à l'étude de ce
projet de loi et au regard de l'article
1 je constate que vont continuer sur
cette voie en triplant le plafond de la
prime macron 2000 à 3000 euros cette
stratégie n'est pas viable sur le lot
sur le temps long en ce sens qu'elle
crée des effets d'aubaine pour les
entreprises en effet à court terme leurs
salariés touchent plus pour un coût
maîtrisé et à long terme des salaires
restent bas les salariés sont eux
perdant sur presque tous les plans un
leurs revenus deviennent imprévisibles
parce qu'une a distribué par l'état peut
disparaître à tout moment alors qu'un
salaire ne peut être basse et de façon
unilatérale par l'employeur 2 leur
progression salariale de progression
salariale de carrière est nécessairement
ralenti
3 ils cotisent moins pour leur retraite
car ces revenus ne sont pas soumis à
cotisations sociales
monsieur le ministre
accepter un débat clair et juste sur ce
sujet je joue propose avec le groupe
sert de convoquer un grenelle des
salaires réunissant à la rentrée les
partenaires sociaux les partenaires
patronaux l'état et les parlementaires
pour aborder la juste répartition des
salaires et un évidement de
l'augmentation r6 losique la parole est
un monsieur chanterelles
merci monsieur le président ce qu'on
peut constater c'est que ce texte il est
clairement pas à la hauteur de la
situation économique et sociale de notre
pays à tel point qu'à mon avis vous
reviendrai certainement devant nous avec
un nouveau texte dans très peu de temps
peut-être dès la reprise de la session
au mois d'octobre pourquoi n'est-il pas
la hauteur parce que ça a été très bien
dit par mes collègues précédent parce
que vous n'agissez pas réellement là où
il faut agir quand on veut augmenter le
pouvoir d'achat
de nos compatriotes à commencer par le
revenu minimum que vous venez de rejeter
à travers une alliance du bloc bourgeois
la lr la rm main dans la main quand il
s'agit de combattre les plus démunis de
notre société vous arrivez toujours à
trouver un accord ça il ya aucun
problème vous vous entendez à l'éveil et
nous pouvons constater en tout cas cette
union qui a été confirmée à travers ce
vote donc si vous voulez agir gagnons du
temps et n'attendons pas un mois deux
mois où la situation va encore
s'aggraver donc augmenter le salaire
minimum c'est un préalable on va
proposer aussi des amendements que nous
souhaitons que vous adoptez concernant
le gel de l'indicé de référence des
loyers ça a été dit aussi par mon
collègue l'organisation d'une conférence
nationale sur les salaires revalorisés
les prestations sociales au moins au
niveau de l'inflation au minimum
d'autant plus que la majorité est
peut-être que bloc bourgeois va encore
s'unir contre les plus pauvres parce
qu'il ya un amendement de la honte dans
l'article 5 qui est de diminuer alors
que c'est déjà pas beaucoup augmenté de
détricoter encore l'aide pour les
personnes qui touchent le rsa mais avez
vous déjà touché le rsa vous pensez
qu'on peut vivre avec le rsa c'est quand
même scandaleux par contre voulait pas
taxer les superprofits ça a été très
bien dit la totale a fait des records de
profit et même un article qui est sorti
aujourd'hui je vous conseille à lire que
en plus il ne paye pas cette entreprise
ne payent pas d'impôts sur la société en
france aussi bien en 2020 2021 quand
allez-vous être décidée à agir et à
taxer ceux qui profitent de la crise
pour répartir les richesses pour les
plus démunis et aider réellement les
personnes et en ont besoin dans ce pays
merci monsieur chantonne monsieur
assouline
oui nous sommes dans un nous sommes dans
un débat préalable de fond quand même
sur les visions de la situation et de la
société
très franchement on peut continuer à
parler de crise de la démocratie
de rejet des élites
pleurait pleurait et ne pas comprendre
que tout cela est le produit d'une
situation qui n'a cessé de s'aggraver
qui devient plus tenable ça ne tiendra
plus mais si vous voulez si vous voulez
on peut remonter à sarkozy a tout ce que
vous voulez je suis là en train
d'essayer de voir si on peut regarder
les choses en face dans la situation
actuelle donc aujourd'hui tout
simplement
chacun sait que si on décourage le fait
que parce que l'on travaille on peut
vivre au moins dignement le minimum on a
vécu 30 ans avec le cheval le chômage de
masse où on nous disait si tu as un
boulot tu es heureux et c'est vrai que
par rapport à cette masse de jeunes qui
ne trouvaient pas de jeu de travail il y
avait quelque chose qui était entendent
abl ça s'est dégradé de plus en plus
parce que on a joué sur le chômage pour
dire aux gens vous ne pouvez pas
progressé vous ne pouvez pas avoir des
salaires plus élevés et maintenant avec
l'inflation tout explose parce que ce
n'est pas les mêmes salaires qu'ils ont
qui était déjà petit c'est moins ils ne
peuvent pas au 10 du mois on disait le
15 du mois et ça va péter pour ceux qui
pensent qu'on ne peut agir que quand ça
va péter parce que leur intérêt et leurs
profits sont mis en danger nous dit-on
les travailleurs mais vous vous pouvez
comprendre qu'à un moment donné même
pour vous ça va plus tenir pour tout ce
que vous soutenez oui quand je dis vous
ce que vous soutenez et donc je veux
finir en disant que dans ce débat ne pas
avoir compris qu'il faut pour encourager
le travail pour parler de valeur travail
et revaloriser les salaires c'est dû
mais rossi majeur merci allez dernier
orateur monsieur fabien gay par ces
raisons monsieur nice en 2019 on était
réunie dans ce même hémicycle vous était
venu c'était les mêmes ministres bruno
le maire était déjà ministre de
l'économie monsieur le ministre qui
était secrétaire d'état aux comptes
publics avait la loi pacte
et vous nous avez dit dans c'était la
partie 3 c'était déjà le même titre
partage de la valeur et on va tout
régler
participation intéressement action de
l'arrière salariés prime et lorsqu'on
parlait de salaire c'était interdit
s'était même has been et c'était en
pleine crise des gilets jaunes et vous
avez dit avec ça on va tout régler trois
ans après on y revient et rien n'est
réglé alors évidemment il ya une crise
économique entre temps et nous sommes
pas dans les mêmes conditions mais si
l'inflation continue à peser autant sur
les ménages français de toute façon quoi
qu'il arrive nous serons obligés d'y
revenir et un moment donné que vous le
voulez ou non nous serons obligés de
passer par le salaire ce que le salaire
c'est y compris et on l'a redit on va
continuer à vous le dire il ya la part
nette mais il ya la part brut et il ya
la part des cotisations aussi patronale
c'est aussi du salaire différé qui
permettent de nourrir notre modèle
social et la sécurité sociale auquel
d'ailleurs vous voulez vous attaquer
avec vos projets de grande sécurité
sociale qui n'a rien à voir avec la
prime d'activité qui vous donner d'une
main bosch et vous reprenez de la main
droite avec l'impôt il faut que ça soit
le capital est donc le travail qui paye
et qui rémunère et donc qui est un
partage de la valeur et puis dernière
chose seul ministre picchu ici on
m'explique que ans ne règle par la loi
que les cadres général et pas les cas
particuliers problèmes avec la prime
macron sait que seulement 16% des
salariés l'ont touché et en plus en
moyenne même pas le plafond 546 euros et
donc 84 % des salariés même vous pouvez
triplé même voire quadrupler plafond ils
ne toucheront rien donc vous faites une
loi pour une minorité et 22 millions de
salariés sont aujourd'hui exemple
documentation et de revenus et surtout
de salaire dont commerces et aux bien
aller
mes chers collègues il ya quarante six
amendements sur l'article 1
après tout les prises de parole je suis
sûr que ça va aller beaucoup plus vite
d'autant que nous avons et je vous
demande d'être assez attentif 27
amendements discussion commune dès le
début le 359 madame lui ben
oui monsieur le président nous avons
bien compris que
nous avons vu même que le smic ne
seraient pas augmentés alors à défaut
d'augmenter le smic nous nous n'aimons
pas beaucoup un tout ce qui est des
socialisation vous l'avez compris aussi
donc si vous entendez persisté dans ses
mesures discrétionnaires de primes
réservées une poignée de salariés nous
nous refusons que celles ci soient
versés au détriment du financement de la
sécurité sociale et donc à terme de la
protection sociale de tous les français
les cotisations sociales sont synonymes
de salaire différé jeudi tout à l'heure
c'est pourquoi vous proposons de taxer
les grands groupes profiteurs de crise
pour financer les primes macron
aléatoire et discrétionnaires ou à
défaut nous re socialiser ces primes qui
ne profite qu'à quelques-uns à fait que
celles-ci ne soient pas payés par la
baisse des droits sociaux de touche
merci
amendement 200 alors trois amendements
identiques le 257 oui monsieur mais non
monsieur lagourgue par blue mais si
monsieur le président c'est un moment
permettre d'attribuer plusieurs primes
ppv chaque année dans la limite du
plafond actuellement la prime ppv peut
être versée en que je tranche mais le
pet décidé qu'une fois l'an
pourtant si d'ordinaire la majorité des
entreprises ont peu de visibilité sur le
rallye sur la réalisation de leur
chiffre d'affaires et leur situation
financière en cours d'année dans la
conjoncture économique incertaine que
nous connaissons la prévision devient
ardu elles sont donc contraintes soin de
limiter le montant de la paix pv à un
montant le moins risqué possible soit
d'attendre la fin la période
d'attribution pour s'assurer de la
capacité à l'inversé le mécanisme de la
ppd pourrait adapter pour permettre à
l'employeur de verser une ou plusieurs
primes pbv durant la période de
référence dans la limite du plafond
global de la ppb déjà fixées par la loi
et en veillant à ne pas procéder à des
versements mensuels assimilable à du
salaire est ainsi à préserver le
caractère exceptionnel de la prime les
salariés pour ainsi bénéficier du
montant des primes plus élevées dans la
limite du plafond de la ppd et se
verrait verser plus rapidement si
monsieur iacovelli le 369
monsieur le président monsieur ministre
sheikh coller avec cet amendement comme
le précédent vise à permettre aux
entreprises de verser la prime de
partage sur la valeur en plusieurs fois
par an en effet cette dans la version
actuelle du texte qui prévoit une prime
qui pourrait être versé en une seule
fois en plusieurs tranches mais décidée
en une seule fois par an au regard de la
conjoncture économique qui est
incertaine un certain nombre
d'entreprises n'ont pas eu de visibilité
ou ne pourront pas avoir de visibilité
sur la réalisation du chiffre d'affaires
dans en cours de l'année cette situation
dont pourrait donc contraindre les
entreprises à limiter le montant de la
prime de partage sur la valeur ou
attendre la fin de la période
d'attribution afin d'en minimiser
minimiser les risques cet amendement
donc propose d'adapter le mécanisme de
la prime de partage de la valeur en
permettant à l'employeur d'en verser une
ou plusieurs durant la période de
référence dans la limite du plafond
global fixé par le projet de loi c
d'adaptation permettrait donc aux
salariés de bénéficier de montants de
primes plus élevées sans attendre la fin
de la période et le 380 à vous pouvez
pas être de 1 mais monsieur non monsieur
le ministre il a été défendu bien sûr je
veux juste insisté sur l'esprit de
souplesse de cet amendement vis-à-vis
notamment d des entreprises des toutes
petites entreprises et de faciliter le
versement de cette prime je vous
remercie merci le 114 monsieur madame
percée mouche
merci monsieur le président cet
amendement vise à renault mais je dirais
à bien nommé la prime exceptionnelle du
pouvoir d'achat primes potentielles du
pouvoir d'achat potentiel car cette
prime on l'a dit est versée au bon
vouloir mettons au bon pouvoir des
entreprises en 2020 5 02 millions de
salariés en 2021 3,3 et 1,8 à ce jour
autrement dit 22 millions de salariés
n'ont pas bénéficié
potentiel également car le triplement de
la pelure prime restera un effet d
annonce en effet le montant autorisé
jusqu'à présent étaient 2000 ou 2000 et
le montant moyen de la paix pas verser
de 2019 à cette année-là de 542 547 ce
n'est pas en triple le montant autorisé
compte triplera le montant versé c'est
une pensée magique mais une vraie mesure
de communication est ce pour les cinq
pour cent alors de bénéficiaires qui ont
touché le plafond de 1000 euros 5 % des
bénéficiaires c'est à dire dans les
secteurs aux plus fortes rémunérations
dans les 38 % d'entreprises qui ont des
accords d'auteur d'arv des accords
d'intéressement
monsieur le ministre vous fait pleuvoir
où c'est mouillé selon le groupe
écologiste ces primes il devra donc ça
peut les primes potentielles du pouvoir
d'achat et aurait même pu s'appeler
prime d'aggravation des inégalités de
revenus entre les salariés
merci le 453 monsieur le ministre
amendement du gouvernement
merci monsieur le président il s'agit là
d'un des points de divergence que j'ai
évoqué ce matin puisque la commission
des affaires sociales du sénat
valide et si je vous dis en tout cas
approuvé la création ou la part dont la
reconduction de la prime exceptionnelle
de pouvoir d'achat réservées aux
salariés gagnant moins de trois smic
jusqu'au 31 décembre 2000 23 et a
souhaité limiter dans le temps la
possibilité de prime de partage de la
valeur qui concerne l'intégralité des
salariés sans plafond de salaire qui est
soumise au régime fiscal et social de
l'intéressement et a souhaité limiter
cette disposition au 31 décembre 2000 23
pour les entreprises de plus de 50
salariés de la maintenance ou de la
queue pour les entreprises de moins de
50 salariés donc le gouvernement
souhaite que ce dispositif nouveau de
partage de la valeur puisse concerner
toutes les entreprises et ce au delà du
31 décembre 2000 23 donc ça a été un
moment de rétablissement
merci monsieur le ministre le 22 madame
la varde au nom de la commission des
finances oui merci monsieur le président
donc effectivement c'est un amendement
qui a été adopté par la commission des
finances et qui vise un peu à recentrer
le dispositif de la prime notamment pour
qu'ils ne viennent pas phagocyter les
dispositifs d'intéressement qui a été
voulu par le précédent gouvernement
laissant la possibilité en fait aux
salariés qui ne souhaiteraient pas
bénéficier d'une prime en numéraire de
pouvoir en fait verser le montant de
cette prime soit sur des dispose d'un
des dispositifs d'intéressement soit sur
des plans d'épargné entreprise donc
d'essayer de s'inscrire dans la
continuité ce qui avait été voulue
précédemment
merci
nous passons à deux amendements
identiques le sens monsieur lagourgue
cet amendement vise avancer la date à
partir de laquelle il est possible de
verser de la prime de pouvoir d'achat en
effet c'est un entreprises ont versé la
prime en juillet et des les annonces du
gouvernement
identique le 404 monsieur iacovelli oui
messieurs président monsieur ministre
sir collègues parfois les temps peu la
réalité ce s'entremêlent entre l'
annonce réaliser l'examen parlementaire
en cours certains citoyens ont déjà mis
en oeuvre en fait les les primes parfois
oui le citoyen se saisit directement des
propositions faites au niveau national
quand nous n'avons pas eu encore le
temps de l'examiner et et de le voter
donc cet amendement prévoit d'avancer au
1er juillet 2022 la date à partir de
laquelle il est possible de verser la
prime de partage de valeurs dans les
conditions prévues par l'article 1er en
effet dans sa version actuelle le texte
prévoit que cette prime pourrait être
versée à partir du 1er août toutefois
afin de soutenir le pouvoir d'achat des
salariés et convient de rappeler qu'un
certain nombre d'entreprises ont déjà
verser la prime au mois de juillet est
donc à la suite des annonces du
gouvernement et à la présentation du
projet de loi avancé d'un mois le
versement de la prime de partage de la
valeur répondants quelle nécessité de
protéger les entreprises qui agissent
pour soutenir le pouvoir d'achat et les
salariés qui bénéficient de cette prime
c'est le 137 monsieur hainaut
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre cet amendement concerne
l'emploi direct à domicile 1 qui compte
3,3 millions de particuliers et emploie
plus de 1,3 million de salariés plus de
5 millions de personnes qui constitue
une véritable société civile organisée
au service de l'intérêt général le
service de l'emploi à domicile constitue
la réponse aux besoins de vie du
quotidien et organise l'emploi de
proximité qualifiée et solidaire or une
ambiguïté subsiste quant à l'éligibilité
des millions de salariés de particuliers
employeurs à la prime de partage de la
valeur instituée par l'article 1er du
projet de loi
l'emploi direct à domicile représentant
une masse salariale
nette de 8,2 milliards d'euros en 2020
l'éligibilité à un tel dispositif paraît
indispensable tant il correspondrait un
potentiel gains de pouvoir d'achat pour
plusieurs millions de salariés sans
qu'il n'en coûte davantage pour les
finances publiques en conséquence cet
amendement vise à s'assurer de
l'éligibilité des particuliers
employeurs dans la prime de partage de
la valeur je vous remercie merci le 322
madame poncet mange
merci le président en encourageant les
employeurs à recourir de plus en plus à
des prime exceptionnelle exonérée le
gouvernement permet aux entreprises de
substituer aux deux salaires pérenne
l'octroi de primes l'insee concluait en
2020 que plus de la moitié de
l'augmentation du salaire moyen par tête
était imputable imprime pépin dont 0,3
point de pur effet d'aubaine sans cette
opportunité cette part on redonne donc
donné lieu à cotisations impôts 3
contributif et augmentation pérenne du
salaire
l'institut constate également que les
salaires progressent moins vite dans les
entreprises ayant versé une prime que
dans celles qui se maintiennent
confirmant l'étude l'alertent de l'étude
d'impact sur le risque de freinage des
revalorisations salariales de ces
dispositifs
ces dispositifs qui encourage à
augmenter la part variable et
discrétionnaire du salaire et comprimer
la part fixe qui pourtant facilite
l'accès à des biens tels logements
le conseil d'état ne s'y est pas trompé
qui déclare que la liberté de choix
laissée à l'employeur dans la
répartition de la prime de partage de la
valeur ne permet pas de garantir qu'elle
contribuera effectivement à la
protection du pouvoir d'achat et en
particulier qui en bénéficiera
substantiellement au plus bas salaires
le conseil d'état donc et pas simplement
la gauche de l'hémicycle or la lutte
contre l'insécurité sociale suite à une
inflation galopante devrait renforcer
plutôt la résilience collective à
prétendent alerte cet amendement
conditionne les exonérations de prime à
la conclusion d'un accord d'entreprise
portant sur la revalorisation salariale
de l'ensemble de leurs branches mais de
leur grille pardon merci le 34 madame la
présidente de l'ordre merci monsieur le
président mes chers collègues la prime
de pouvoir d'achat bonne chose et tout
particulièrement le relèvement de son
plafond pour atteindre 6000 euros dans
le contexte de forte inflation et de
tensions considérables sur le pouvoir
d'achat que nous connaissons aujourd'hui
si nous pensons fort justement aux
salariés aux ouvriers à toutes celles et
ceux qui ont des contrats dits
classiques et rentrer sous le coup des
critères de conditionnalité il
m'apparaît pourtant nécessaire et c'est
un constat partagé par l'ensemble des
signataires de cet amendement de ne pas
oublier certains travailleurs notamment
jeunes je pense aux apprentis ou vous
savez comme présidente de la gasse que
je suis particulièrement attaché à
l'apprentissage donc aux apprentis lié
par un contrat d'apprentissage au sens
du code du travail mais aussi aux
stagiaires il ya une entreprise par une
convention régis par le code de
l'éducation
encore une fois cette prime n'est pas
une obligation de l'employeur mais la
désocialisation et la défiscalisation
sont particulièrement incitative je
tiens à ce qu'elle le soit pour le plus
grand nombre pour que l'employeur ait
cette possibilité de donner un coup de
pouce au delà du minimum légal qui est
la plupart du temps prévu dans ses
contrats c'est une façon de récompenser
les efforts déployés nous devons nous en
assurer car c'est une question de
justice sociale et un devoir commun de
soutenir nos jeunes notre avenir merci
merci le
380 18 monsieur lagourgue puis vous
défendrez le 251 merci ancré dans les
territoires à taille humaine et proche
de la salariés des pme et des nti ce
sont ces six derniers mois de l'urgence
du pouvoir d'achat les revalorisations
salariales tous dispositifs confondus
s'élève selon les secteurs et des
tailles d'entreprises 5 à 10% en 2022
afin d'encourager cette mobilisation
c'est amendements permettraient de
verser une prime universelle
exceptionnelle défiscalisées et
désocialisés allant jusqu'à 2000 euros à
l'ensemble des salariés quel que soit le
niveau de rémunération d'exonération du
forfait social sur ainsi maintenu pour
une première tranche de distribution à
l'ange jusqu'au 10 montant au delà de
celui ci le régime fiscal et social du
dispositif pérenne de primes de pouvoir
d'achat s'appliquerait alors que deux
tiers du pays envisage de verser une
prime de pouvoir d'achat en 2022 et
qu'elles ont à coeur de préserver la
cohésion du collectif en traitant
équitablement l'ensemble de la salariée
la coexistence de deux régimes de prime
suivant le niveau de rémunération sion
et singulièrement l'asus
l'assujettissement au forfait social
d'une partie des primes sont de nature à
brider le recours à ce dispositif
exceptionnel et d'amputer les montants
distribués dès lors il convient de mieux
calibrer ce dispositif d'urgence pour en
faire bénéficier l'ensemble des couleurs
des collaborateurs dans la continuité de
la prime exceptionnelle pour le pouvoir
d'achat cet amendement vise donc à
mettre en oeuvre une prime universel
défiscalisées et désocialisés d'un
montant maximum de 2000 euros à
destination de l'ensemble des salariés
des pme des deux pays pour répondre aux
problématiques de pouvoir d'achat dans
un contexte économique inflationnistes
51 cet amendement temps d'une part à
permettre aux employeurs des tribunes
prime défiscaliser de façon
trimestrielle plutôt qu'annuelle et
d'autre part a doublé pour l'année son
montant cela permet aux salariés d'avoir
un budget plus en adéquation avec nos
besoins
temps 49 madame cohen oui merci monsieur
le président vous aurez compris lors de
nos interventions au niveau du groupe
communiste républicain citoyen
écologistes nous ne sommes pas
favorables aux primes et à
l'augmentation des salaires ce qui a été
battu ici dans l'hémicycle mais nous
avons un autre problème justement
concernant les primes c'est aussi le
fait que vous exode vous exonérer de
cotisations ses primes et pour nous nous
n'arrêtons pas de le dénoncer notamment
lors de l'examen du budget de la
sécurité sociale le fait que ces
exonérations se multiplient grèvent le
budget de la sécurité sociale et vous en
rajoutez une couche alors effectivement
vous opposer à cet argument et vous
allez sans doute le dire monsieur le
ministre mais ça va être composé pour
compenser à l'euro près moi je suis très
heureuse que notre camarade pierre
dharréville au niveau de l'assemblée
nationale ait eu l'intelligence de
déposer un amendement qui d'ailleurs
fort heureusement a été adopté pour que
effectivement ces compensations soit
totalement faite au niveau de l'état
conformément d'ailleurs au code de la
sécurité sociale mais au final à partir
du moment où vous exonérer de
cotisations sociales c'est un manque à
gagner voulvoul e comblés avec de
l'argent de l'état mais du coup c'est un
double manque à gagner et ceux qui en
pâtissent ce sont les habitantes et les
habitants de notre pays ce sont des
services publics en moins ce sont les
services rendus en moins et vous ne
pouvez pas nous dire circulez ya rien à
voir obligatoirement ça fait de l'argent
en moins pour améliorer la vie
quotidienne de nos concitoyennes et de
nos concitoyens parmi les plus les plus
précaires je crois qu'il faut être
conscient finalement de la part de plus
en plus grand qu est prise par ces
exonérations dans nos comptes publics et
dans un projet de loi de plus de 18
milliards d'euros nous l'avons déjà
dénoncé il n'y a aucun centime de
contributions de la part des entreprises
c'est vraiment lourd de sens un symbole
et franchement ça ne rend pas
personnaliser notre merci le 42 monsieur
can't even merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre chers collègues je
pense que c'est un excellent dispositif
que cette prime de partage de la valeur
qu'il convient d'encourager
effectivement parce qu'il n'y a pas de
raison que le partage de la valeur ne
s'effectue pas dans les entreprises il
n'y a pas que les actionnaires qui
doivent bénéficier mais les salariés
bien entendu qu'ils contribuent
également mais il me semble que le
défaut de cette prime c'est qu'elle ne
serve qu'à être dépensé tout de suite or
il faut aussi qu'on puisse permettre il
faut qu'on s'y qu'on puisse permettre à
ceux qui ont envie de l'épargné de le
faire comme cela se passe dans les
dispositifs traditionnels de
l'entreprise c'est-à-dire les
dispositifs d'intéressement notamment et
donc il n'y avait pas de raisons tu as
eu un rôle allait il n'y a pas de raison
que ce qu'ils veulent l'épargné et la
permettre les parias en longue durée qui
va d'ailleurs au bénéfice d'entreprises
puisque ça sert pour le développement
des entreprises dans notre pays il n'y a
pas de raison que cela ne puisse pas se
faire et donc c'est l'objet de cet
amendement de laisser le libre choix aux
salariés d'affecter le produit de la
prime de partage de la peur soit à la
dépense immédiate choix aux placements
dans les dispositifs d'intéressement
d'entreprise
merci
90 madame de seine
merci monsieur le président cet
amendement vise à clarifier à sécuriser
les conditions dell asus getis mans de
la prime de partage de la valeur
lorsqu'elle est versée aux salariés
intérimaires mise à disposition
d'entreprises utilisatrices il est donc
ainsi précisé que cette prime est
soumise au taux de contribution
applicable à l'entreprise utilisatrice
et non à celui de l'entreprise de
travail temporaire
merci le 151 monsieur guay
merci monsieur le président celui c'est
dommage que michel soit partie parce qu
on aurait eu un petit débat je pense que
lorsqu'on est au smic et compte toucher
une prime de 546 euros je pense que le
débat s'est pas épargné ou pas sont là
des passes de suite parce que ça devient
une nécessité
mais bon c'est le débat que nous allons
prolonger pendant trois jours
c'est un amendement de roblique je
présente puisqu'on veut conditionner les
exonérations aux entreprises qui
respectent un écart de 1 à 20 dans les
rémunérations
j'entends beaucoup depuis le départ que
nous sommes le premier pays
où on taxe les entreprises le plus
fortement dans le lot c d e oui mais on
est aussi le pays où on aide le plus le
capital
90 milliards d'euros de cotisations
exonérées de cotisations chaque année et
220 milliards d'euros au repos vite des
deux entreprises directe ou indirecte
donc en france on a le capitalisme libre
fossé est le mieux aider au monde il
faut se le dire parce que sinon on prend
pas tous les bouts de la chaîne et donc
sur cette question des exonérations que
nous ne partageons pas mais s'il faut
carnet nous proposons de les
conditionner au minimum à celle qui
respecte un écart de 1 à 20 nous pensons
surtout aux entreprises du cac 40
l'écart moyen dans les entreprises du
cac 40 ces 2 1 à 2 139 smic dassault
c'est plus de 1000 smic et nous pensons
au minimum que un écart raisonnable est
de 1 à 20 voilà je vous remets
merci le sens
150 12
252 qui le défendent adam cole merci
monsieur le président dans le même
esprit que l'amendement qui vient d'être
défendu par mon collègue notre collègue
fabien gay nous proposons de
conditionner les exonérations de
cotisations sociales de la prime de
partage de la valeur à une réduction des
inégalités entre les femmes et les
hommes donc vous êtes pour les
exonérations et au moins il faut les
conditionner
je ne vous apprends rien en disant que
malgré les lois successives l'égalité
salariale n'est toujours pas une réalité
en france et loin s'en faut pour rappel
chaque jour c'est comme si dès 16h à peu
près les femmes travaillaient
gratuitement les causes sont bien connus
ça a été dit je le redis pour faire vite
une sous valorisation des métiers dits
féminins et des sanctions qui ne sont
pas assez dissuasives quant à l'index
d'égalité professionnelle mis en place
il est vraiment largement insuffisant et
d'ailleurs dénoncée par la majorité des
syndicats quand on sait que les plus bas
salaires sont occupés par les femmes
quand on sait que les familles
monoparentales sont essentiellement
composés de mer et quand il est ici
question de pouvoir d'achat mes chers
collègues on aurait pu s'attendre à une
attention particulière sur l'égalité
salariale mais j'ai l'impression que ce
gouvernement finalement ressemble
décidément trait pour trait au précédent
et que malgré les belles promesses de
changement les femmes vont devoir encore
attendre souffrir et lutter alors
franchement face à l'urgence et à la
gravité de la situation
notre amendement est plutôt modéré
puisqu'il propose uniquement d'instaurer
comme condition au maintien des
exonérations sociales de la prime de
partage de la valeur l'ouverture de
négociations sur l'égalité
professionnelle entre les femmes et les
hommes tous les ans c'est quand même à
mon avis la moindre des choses et
j'espère qu'au moins là le sénat votera
cet amendement merci le 153 mais si
monsieur le président dans la continuité
de mes collègues nous souhaitons avoir
un débat avec cet amendement sur la
pertinence de soutenir financièrement
les entreprises qu'ils ont un recours
abusif aux contrats à temps partiel il
ya un risque d'effets d'aubaine pour les
entreprises alors que les employés à
temps partiel sont déjà frappés d'une
double peine moins d'heures d'une part
et moins de salaire de l'autre parent en
effet il ya ceux qui souhaitent ou qu'on
a besoin de deux mois qu'ils souhaitent
de travailler à temps partiel mais y en
a beaucoup qui subissent le temps
partiel et qui n'en veulent pas cette
précarité subi est particulièrement vrai
pour les femmes qui représentent
80% des contrats à temps partiel il est
indispensable d'encourager les
entreprises à recruter à temps complet
et d'éviter de soutenir indirectement
les entreprises qui recrutent
majoritairement à temps partiel c'est
pourquoi notre amendement propose
d'exclure du bénéfice des exonérations
des cotisations sociales les entreprises
ou les contrats à temps partiel qui
dépasse va pourtant de la masse
salariale totale merci merci le 250 de
monsieur lagourgue
mais si le président cet amendement a
créé pour les chefs d'entreprises
employant moins de 5 50 salariés la
faculté de verser une prime de partage
de la valeur de mon temps nhk 6000 euros
sans être contraint par la condition de
voir mises en oeuvre ou conclut un
dispositif d'intéressement ou de
participation
en effet l'article premier du projet de
loi prévoit tripler le montant de la
prime de partage de la valeur par
rapport à la prime exceptionnelle de
pouvoir d'achat qui avait court jusqu'en
mars 2022 et dont la ppb s'inspire ce
montant peut aller jusqu'à 3000 euros
par bénéficiaire et par année et jusqu'à
6000 euros lorsque la pp versée pour une
entrée par une entreprise qui met en
oeuvre un dispositif d'intéressement par
un organisme d'intérêt général ou
s'agissant des primes versées aux
travailleurs handicapés par leur
établissement au service d aide par le
travail de fait de tels dispositifs
reste compliquée à mettre en oeuvre pour
les entreprises de proximité dont
l'immense majorité comptent moins de 50
salariés notamment parce qu'ils engagent
l'entreprise trois ans dans un contexte
où des bénéfices d'une année ne soit de
garantie polonais en plus a fortiori
pour l'année en plus de cet amendement
s'inspire de l'esprit de l'article 4 de
la loi de finances rectificative pour
2021 qui autorisait les entreprises de
moins de 50 salariés à verser la prime
exceptionnelle de pouvoir d'achat
jusqu'à un montant de 2000 euros sans
conditions liées à la mise en oeuvre
d'un dispositif d'intéressement au même
titre que les associations et les
fondations mentionnées aux articles a et
b des articles 200 et 230 8 bis du code
général des impôts si le 380 monsieur
hainaut
mais monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre cet amendement vise à supprimer
pour les tpe la condition de mise en
place d'un dispositif d'intéressement
pour accéder à un montant de prime
revalorisé à 6000 euros en effet
l'obligation de conclure un accord
d'intéressement peut représenter une
contrainte administrative et dissuasif
pour ces toutes petites entreprises de
moins de dix salariés qui n'ont pas
toujours de services de ressources
humaines ou comptables et dont les chefs
d'entreprise doivent parfois concilier
la présence sur les chantiers ou dans
leur commerce tout en assurant eux mêmes
toutes les démarches administratives les
tpe représentent 94% des entreprises
françaises il paraît opportun de lever
ce frein à l'attribution de la prime de
la valeur ajoutée pour qu'elle bénéficie
à plus de salariés possible je vous
remercie merci le 23 à madame la varde
et je m'excuse de vous faire sortir
quelques toiles la commission d'évidence
mais tous deux mettent en même temps
exactement penser les contraintes du
travail parlementaire en ce moment mais
cet amendement fait vise à introduire de
l'équité fiscale en fait dans l'est
entre les bénéficiaires de la prime
puisque dans la rédaction actuelle en
fait la défiscalisation et fonction
uniquement des revenus du celui qui la
perçoit sans tenir compte des revenus de
l'ensemble du ménage et notamment des
personnes qui déclarerait de manière
commune et donc en fait l'amendement
propose comme de toute façon la
défiscalisation allez faites au moment
de la déclaration d'impôts qu'on tienne
compte de l'ensemble des revenus du
ménage tout en gardant les mêmes
conditions de plafonds donc quand une
personne déclare seul c'est bien en
dessous de trois smic quand une personne
déclare à deux ça sera en dessous de
sismique est ce qui permet d'introduire
en fait une égalité puisque dans le
régime actuel si le bénéficiaire est
juste en dessous de trois smic et que
son conjoint gagne 8 fois le smic sa
prime seraient défiscalisées alors que
dans une même si tu a sion quelqu'un qui
aurait 3,1 smic ça primes seraient
fiscalisées même si son conjoint ne
gagne que 1,2 smic donc voilà ce que
propose cet amendement merci le 444
madame la rapporteure rédactionnelles
merci le 123 madame poncet mange
merci monsieur le président eh bien
écoutez notre amendement va tenir compte
des interventions précédentes et va
rétablir effectivement l'égalité entre
les entreprises qui ont ou qui n'ont pas
un accord
d'intéressement puisque nous nous
proposons de supprimer le doublement en
cas d'accord d'intéressement les accords
d'intéressement sont un outil bon qu'il
y des salariés à la performance est
souvent à la rentabilité de l'entreprise
or à l'amont la hausse des bénéfices
d'entreprises va pouvoir permettre une
augmentation des salaires de la même
manière qu'elle aboutit actuellement à
une augmentation spectaculaire et
continue de l'arrêt rémunération des pdg
cela a été dit en 2021 selon les calculs
de la plateforme skylands la
rémunération moyenne a loué au pdg du
cac 40 a bondi de 8,7 millions d'euros
soit près du double des 4,5 millions de
2020 et où en sont les augmentations de
salaires des employés
selon l'insee en décembre 2021 le taux
de marge des entreprises s'est envolé
aux alentours de 36 pour cent soit son
plus haut niveau depuis 1949 or cette
augmentation n'est pas le fruit du
hasard elle a été permise par la
décorrélation dans les années 80 entre
les salaires et l'inflation ne sorte que
la part des salaires dans le pib a
fortement diminué depuis tandis que les
taux de marge des entreprises ne cessent
eux d'atteindre des records chaque année
car il s'agit bien du partage des
richesses créées ou la compression de la
part des rémunérations du travail
alimente de facto l'augmentation des
taux de marge l'intéressement ne doit
pas devenir l'outil principal de
restitution aux salariés de la valeur
qu'ils ont contribué à l'ams on a créé
au détriment donc du salaire par
conséquent nous proposons de supprimer
le doublement de l'intéressement qui ne
concerne d'ailleurs que 38% des
entreprises et qui ne répondent en
aucunement au titre de cette loi les
caractères dur
l'inflation merci merci le 250 et le
sang un monsieur lagourgue puisque vous
présenter les 150 prêcher président cet
amendement tend à permettre aux salariés
qui en émettent le souhait de verser la
prime de partage de la valeur sur le
plan d'epargne salariale
pour acquérir un logement ou faire face
à des besoins futurs
le saint vith bis rectifié bis la prime
exceptionnelle de partage de la valeur
la paix pas va permettre l'amélioration
du pouvoir d'achat de nombreux salariés
cependant puisque des conditions de
versement de cette prime sont
particulièrement inintérêt intéressante
il est à craindre que le flux de ces
primes ne tarissent le plus abondant le
dispositif de plantes en place de
dépenses salariales or est l effet de
bord conviendrait
contreviendrait à la volonté affichée
par le gouvernement de promouvoir et de
développer ceux ci au premier rang
desquels intéressant en effet la paix
pas comme des dispositifs dépenses
salariales n'ont vocation à se
substituer à aucun élément de
rémunération
l'epargne salariale demeure
essentiellement financée par le flux
versées par l'entreprise participation
intéressement abondement dont les frais
sont pris en charge en entreprises et
qui constitue pour de nombreux salariés
sur les pentes financière c'est une
épargne majoritairement investis en
actions et obligations privées qui
financent les entreprises c'est tendance
a été accentuée par la loi pape qui a
fait chez une part des investissements
faire les fonds dits pe de apm en
instaurant la paypal dont les
caractéristiques font référence au cadre
légal de l'epargne salariale le
gouvernement introduit une concurrence
avec la prime d'intéressement et prend
le risque d'une éviction de
l'intéressement au profit de cette
nouvelle prime ce qui pénalisera le
financement de l'économie productive
l'apepa favorise donc le court terme et
la consommation de biens importés alors
que des dispositifs d'épargné salariale
permettent le financement à long terme
de nos entreprises c'est pourquoi cet
amendement vise à exonérer d'impôts et
de cotisations sociales tous les
versements de la paix pas sur des
dispositifs d'épargné salariale et ce
sans conditions de rémunération
merci
madame la rapporteur sur sur ces 27
amendements essayons de suivre calmement
et d'être très clair de même pour
monsieur le ministre tout à l'heure ça
va être évidemment la clarté absolue
madame la rapporte merci monsieur le
président alors effectivement je vais
tenter d'être clair et peut-être pour
gagner du temps tout en respectant à mes
réponses qui peuvent être rapides et en
respectant mes collègues mes collègues
pardon définir une ligne en tout cas
celle qui a prévalu quand nous avons
défendu ces amendements en commission
d'abord nous avons souhaité que cette
prime reste simple ensuite nous avons
souhaité et tout le monde l'a bien
précisé qu'elle ne se substituent ni aux
salaires ni aux outils classiques de
partage de la valeur que son
l'intéressement et la participation
ensuite nous avons souhaité que cette
prime conserve un avantage fiscal et
social enfin qu'elle ait un effet
d'immédiateté je rappelle qu'on l'ait
sur un texte sur le pouvoir d'achat et
enfin que nous ne perdions pas de vue
que l'intéressé reste quand même le
salarié avec aussi également une
valorisation de l'intéressement et puis
ça c'est un petit bonus je me permets de
le dire parce que je les ai entendus je
voudrais que dans cet hémicycle s'il
vous plaît on évite d'appeler cette
prime prime macron parce que je rappelle
qu'elle n'est absolument pas versé ni
par le gouvernement et encore moins par
le présent la république voilà c'est un
nom qui a été utilisé à tort et je
souhaite effectivement le dire dans
cette émission une fois qu'on s'est dit
ça je vous propose de passer un
amendement par amendement en étant un
peu rapide tout en respectant
effectivement les auteurs de
l'amendement sur le 359 de madame lubin
je cite que les premiers signataires de
2,7 de cet amendement c'est un amant un
amendement qui vise à la suppression de
toutes les exonérations liées à la prime
donc là on supprime la fiscalité donc
c'est contraire à notre philosophie donc
c'est un avis défavorable sur le 257 369
et 381 qui sont donc des amendements
identiques
nous sommes sur des amendements peuvent
peuvent peuvent tourner la page
qui dans l'objet donne la possibilité
d'attribuer la prime en plusieurs fois
dans une année alors pour ces
amendements là c'est ce que j'ai évoqués
en commission
je me permettrais de dire aux auteurs de
ces amendements éventuellement de les
retirer
et de se rallier à l'amendement que je
propose c'est pas tant que je le propose
et qu'il est bon par rapport aux vôtres
mais c'est qu'effectivement il a plus de
précisions il apporte plus de précision
parce que le sens de cet amendement est
intéressant parce qu'effectivement
l'attribution de la prime en plusieurs
fois peut être intéressant mais sauf que
là plusieurs fois ça peut être beaucoup
de fois et que je propose ma simplement
qu'on puisse attribuer la prime à deux
reprises si effectivement ça convient
mais sur le sens ça me paraît être
effectivement intéressant donc c'est une
demande de retrait pour l'amendement 257
369 et 380 en ce qui concerne
l'amendement 114 qui propose une
modification du nom de la primaire j'ai
tristement de mon bien mignon mais je
jeu c'est plutôt un avis défavorable
parce qu'une fois que la prime sera
versée elle sera plus potentiel mais
elle sera effectif en effet en espérant
que beaucoup la touche rond en ce qui
concerne la menthe notamment devant 453
du gouvernement 1 qui vise à revenir sur
la proposition que nous avons faite de
ne pas pérenniser la prime pour les
entreprises depuis 49 salariés c'est
bien entendu un amendement défavorable
monsieur le ministre vous l'avez dit
c'est un c'est un point d'achoppement
sur nos deux positions sur l'amendement
22 de madame la varde qui est un
amendement qui donne la possibilité de
verser la prime sous forme de supplément
d'intéressement on contrevient au
principe de liquidités qui me semble
être important pour le pouvoir d'achat
des français donc c'est un avis
défavorable
l'amendement sans rectifié de monsieur
capture qui est un amendement qui vise à
une anticipation de la prime au 1er
juillet quai identique à l'amendement
400 cas de monsieur iacovelli la cites
un avis favorable parce qu'effectivement
certaines entreprises ont déjà versé
cette prise cette prime je rappelle que
dans le texte de loi elle est effective
au 1er août et certains l'ont déjà
averti au 1er juillet ça monsieur
ministre me permet de lire les effets
d'annoncé du président de la république
ou des membres du gouvernement font
qu'on a un moment donné des difficultés
et que c'est le texte le texte qui est
obligé de rattraper la réalité des
choses en face et un avis favorable à je
suis bien aimable monsieur hinault
l'amendement 137 qui permet une
extension de la faculté de verser la
prime aux particuliers employeurs alors
c'est vrai c'est une question qu'on
s'est posée est ce qu'on aura
effectivement des particuliers qui
donneront une prime telle qu'elle est
sur ce principe là alors monsieur le
ministre j'allais presque dire on vous
demande un avis sur ce sujet là est-ce
que cette prime parce que ce n'est pas
explicite dans le texte est ce que cette
prime est possible en tout cas pour les
particuliers employeurs et à destination
effectivement de ses salariés là donc
c'est un avis du gouvernement sur
l'amendement 137 sur l'amendement 322 de
madame poncet mange qui vident à
conditionner la possibilité de verser la
prime à la conclusion d'un accord
portant sur la revalorisation générale
des salaires de l'entreprise là ça
pénaliserait les salariés dès lors qu'on
aurait des chefs d'entreprise qui ne
rentrerai pas dans cette logique dont
c'est un avis défavorable pour cela
l'amendement 34 de madame delattre qui
permettrait une extension de bénéfice de
la prime aux apprentis aux stagiaires
alors je traiterai cet amendement en
deux parties s'agissant du stagiaire je
considère quand même qu'il est dans
l'entreprise plutôt pour une vertu de
formation qu'une vertu effectivement de
financement donc je d'extraire est entre
guillemets de cet amendement par contre
en ce qui concerne les apprentis je
laisserais monsieur le ministre en parle
et on l'a évoqué à l'occasion de la
préparation de cette séance a priori
c'est oui ils peuvent en bénéficier mais
je laisserai monsieur le ministre en
parle et donc ça serait plutôt une
demande du retrait de retrait au regard
de la position de monsieur le ministre
l'amendement 398 de madame paule dégage
un qui viserait à une exonération
d'impôts et de cotisations sociales sur
la prime hauteur de 2000 euros ce qui
est moins que ce que nous permet
aujourd'hui le texte puisque ces 3000
euros donc je vois peu l'intérêt de cet
amendement donc c'est un avis
défavorable amendement 251 de monsieur
mais non winne qui vise à un
plafonnement de la prime à 1500 euros
par trimestre sans conditions ce qui
ramènerait le plafond à 6000 euros alors
je rappelle et beaucoup ont souligné que
ce plafond de 6000 euros et quand même
un leurre et qu'il faut éviter
effectivement d'avoir trop d'amendements
qui l'évoquent pas ce que certains
pourraient penser qu'on pourrait aller
jusqu'à 6000 euros an je doute que
beaucoup de personnes touchent toucher
une prime à ce niveau là laon des
plafonnerait effectivement le principe
et en contreviendrait au principe de
l'intéressement qui est important sur ce
dispositif donc c'est un avis
défavorable l'amendement 149 de manama
pour ce colis qui vise à la suppression
des exonérations de cotisations sociales
liées au versement de la prime pareil
c'est ce que j'ai dit l'intérêt de la
prime c'est effectivement ces enjeux de
défiscalisation donc c'est un avis
défavorable monsieur calvet l'amendement
42 qui donne la possibilité de verser la
prime sur un plan d'épargne-retraite un
plan d'épargne-entreprise pardon on
contrevient au principe de liquidités
inhérents à ce prop sur le steak sur le
pouvoir d'achat donc c'est un avis
défavorable madame humbert qui a été
présenté par madame de seine
l'amendement 90's de 90 puis par donc
ibiza la soumission des entreprises de
travail temporaire forfait social au
titre de la prime en fonction de leurs
effectifs permanents alors c'est un avis
favorable mais on a très peu abordée
l'enjeu est effectivement des
entreprises intérimaire donc peut-être
monsieur le ministre aura quelque chose
à nous dire sur cet amendement là est le
suivant puisque on traite aussi
dangereux sur les entreprises d'intérim
donc avis favorable à cet amendement
l'amendement 151 madame apourceau poly
qui propose une limitation de
l'exonération lié au versement de la
prime aux entreprises ayant un écart de
rémunération minimale de 1 à 20 là aussi
on contrevient aux principes et ont
pénalisé salariés donc c'est un avis
défavorable
madame apourceau poly ya un amendement
qui vise donc c'est le 152 1 qui vise à
une compte de ces conditionnalités de
l'exonération lié au versement de la
prime au lancement par l'entreprise
pendant l'année civile en cours d'une
négociation sur l'égalité
professionnelle entre les femmes et les
hommes là aussi on peut pénaliser les
salariés par effectivement des
employeurs qui serait peu vertueux en
tout cas qu'ils respecteraient pas un
certain nombre de principes donc c'est
un avis défavorable
l'amendement 153 manama pour ce poli qui
lisent a conditionné la prime et les
exonérations liées au versement de la
prime au respect d'un quota de 20 % de
salariés à temps partiel par
l'entreprise même principe on pourrait
effectivement pénalisé les salariés par
des employeurs peu vertueux donc en
l'occurrence et un avis défavorable le
250 de monsieur mais non ville qui est
un amendement
qui qui est relatif au plafond de prime
de 6000 euros qui serait sans condition
pour les entreprises de moins de 50
salariés là on est à linverse du
dispositif d'intéressement qui est
intéressant dans cet article donc c'est
un avis aussi défavorable la menthe 382
monsieur delcros
c'est un amendement qui vise à ce que le
plafond de 6000 euros soit sans
condition pour la prime de pouvoir
d'achat est distribué par des
entreprises de moins de dix salariés là
aussi on contrevient aux principes
d'intéressement donc c'est un amendement
défavorable l'amendement numéro 23 de
madame la varde qui est un amendement
qui vise à une qui vise à une conjugale
isation alors on a appris le mode éponge
utilisation maintenant points à prendre
après le mot conjugale isation
l'exonération d'impôt sur le revenu au
titre de la prime alors j'entends j'ai
dit que c'était un amendement pur donc
je le redis effectivement dans cet
hémicycle mais ils compliquent un peu le
dispositif donc c'est plutôt un avis
défavorable l'amendement numéro 444 le
mien eh bien écoutez c'est un avis
favorable et rédactionnelles donc il a
peu d'impact l'amendement 123 de madame
poncet mange c'est un amendement qui
vise à supprimer la limite d'exonération
d'impôt sur le revenu de 6000 euros en
cas de cumul l'ancienne prime de pouvoir
d'achat et d'après me définis dans cette
loi en 2022 alors madame pense et moi je
lui ai donné un avis défavorable parce
que je pense que l'amendement que vous
déposé cet amendement où je vous sauf je
pense parce que il n'est pas tout à fait
dans l'esprit de ce que vous évoquez
puisque effectivement le cumul des
primes sur la même année ne peut pas
aller au delà de 6000 euros et vous vous
des plafonniers 6000 euros considérant
qu'on peut aller au delà donc je pense
qu'une erreur d'interprétation donc en
ce sens pour vous sauver je donne un
avis défavorable à l'amendement 252 me
d'amnéville qui vise à exonérer de la
prime diverses imposition et
contribution en cas de versement sur un
compte d'épargné là on est sur un sujet
où ennuis à la disponibilité à primes
dont un avis défavorable et c'est la
même chose pour le moment 101 avec
l'avis défavorable voilà monsieur le
président
merci
monsieur le ministre
sur les 27
[Musique]
sur sur les 27 amendements d'abord vrai
dire un mot de l'état d'esprit qui va
m'amener à donner des avis peut-être
plus brefs sur chaque amendement d'abord
dire que nous sommes nous aussi
extrêmement attaché au caractère liquide
de la prime est donc l'intégralité des
amendements qui visent à permettre à
faciliter le versement de cette prime
directement sur départ des plans
d'épargné entreprise des plans épargne
retraite ou à
autoriser des versements non pas sous
forme de liquidités mais sous forme de
fractions d'intéressement auront un avis
défavorable nous sommes aussi attaché à
une méthode de versement cette méthode
est de prévoir une prime par an avec la
possibilité de la versés de manière
fractionnée et en cela nous partageons
pleinement un amendement adopté par la
commission à l'initiative de madame
lagarde qui limite à quatre le nombre de
versements possible d'une même prime
cela permet d'éviter la mensualisation
et donc d'éviter un effet de substitut
d'un effet de substitution primes
salaires tout en facilitant le versement
de la prime par des entreprises qui
auraient moins
de trésorerie au moment où elle décide
du versement de cette prime là nous
sommes
aussi attaché à ce que la prime puisse
être attribué en fonction des conditions
prévues par le texte c'est à dire la
nécessité d'un accord d'intéressement au
delà 3000 euros et pour celles et ceux
qui défendent la suppression de cette
condition pour permettre le versement de
la prime je rappellerai cependant que
jusqu'à présent la prime était limité à
1000 euros sans accord d'intéressement
et le passage de 1000 à 2000 euros de
plafond était conditionnée à un accord
d'intéressement et donc toutes celles et
ceux qui défendent est le principe de
2000 euros sans conditions d'accord
d'intéressement sont d'une certaine
manière satisfait nous pensons que la le
développement des accords
d'intéressement est tout à fait
essentiel est que le maintien de cette
condition permet justement d'avoir un
effet levier sur le nombre d'accord
d'intéressement de la même manière nous
ne souhaitons pas qu'il y ait de
conditionnement en particulier pour que
cette prime puisse être versée dans les
entreprises je terminerai par deux
points monsieur le président ben donner
la vie amendement par amendement d'abord
pour dire en réponse aux amendements sur
la question de la date que nous sommes
favorables aux amendements qui avancent
la date au 1er juillet ce d'autant plus
que tous les textes de lois qui vont
encadrer les primes exceptionnelles de
pouvoir d'achat jusqu'à présent ont
toujours prévu une date un peu
antérieures pour éviter que ceux qui
avaient décidé de verser la prime soit
sanctionné et je souligne aussi que nous
avons toujours veillé à ce que des
entreprises puissent verser par exemple
la prime de 2021 jusqu'en mars 2022 pour
que celle des entreprises qui avaient
besoin de connaître l'exactitude de
leurs comptes de l'année puisse prendre
la décision malgré ce décalage de date
et je tiens aussi enfin à dire à madame
delattre que je cherche que les
apprentis et c'est une garantie absolue
les apprentis sont éligibles à la prime
puisque les apprentis ont un contrat de
travail et que l'intégralité des
titulaires d'un contrat de travail sont
éligibles à la prime ça vaut aussi
d'ailleurs pour les travailleurs qui
interviennent dans des structures
adaptées ou des entreprises adaptées
dans le cadre d'un contrat de travail je
le précise il n'y a aucune
ambiguïté donc c'est une demande de
retrait les stagiaires ne sont pas
concernés puisqu'ils ne sont pas liées à
l'entreprise par un contrat de travail
enfin un mot sur la question des
compensations d'exonération en réponse à
madame cohen en particulier c'est un
débat que nous avons eu à l'assemblée
est effectivement monsieur darvill avait
présenté un amendement certainement m'a
permis de rappeler que le principe de
compensation prévus par la loi veil de
1994 est respectée depuis 2019 et que la
dernière opération non compensés c'est
l'exonération sur les heures
supplémentaires que vous avez rappelé à
la suite du grand débat je m'étais
engagé devant vous à ce que le
gouvernement ne présente plus au
parlement de mesures d'exonération sans
compensation et 7 non compensation de
2019 était la dernière d'une longue
série de 14 puisque la loi veil de 94 a
été dé roger a connu des dérogations à
14 reprises quelles que soient les
majorités il faut préciser etc jeudi
pour vous rassurer comme j'ai dit à
monsieur dharréville c'est une loi qui
fonctionne avec un principe d' a
contrario pour qu' il n'ya pas
compensation il faut que le gouvernement
inscrive dans le texte il déroge au
principe de compensation dès lors qu'il
n'ait rien inscrire dans un texte la
compensation est automatique puisqu'elle
est prévue par la loi et donc dès lors
que l'on prévoit une exonération il ya
compensation soit a précisé l inverse ce
que nous avions fait il ya trois ans sur
les heures supplémentaires sur les
amendements tels qu'ils ont été
déposées pour le 359 qui concerne une
suppression d'exonérations de
cotisations
l'avis est défavorable les 257 269 et 2
et 3 181 qui prévoit la possibilité de
verser plusieurs primes dans l'année
l'avis est défavorable
nous considérons que c'est une prime
exceptionnelle doit être versée doit
être décidé qu'une fois pour le 114 et
un avis défavorable évidemment je
maintiens l'amendement 453 du
gouvernement malgré l'avis défavorable
de madame la rapporteure puisque c'est
l'un des points de divergence que j'ai
rappelé à deux reprises pour le 22 de
madame la varde c'est un avis
défavorable puisque ce serait versée
sous forme d'intéressement une
considérant que ce sont deux dispositifs
qui doivent être distincts pour les
amendements sont et 404 qui modifie la
date d'entrée en vigueur c'est un avis
favorable pour l'amendement 137 de
monsieur hainaut pour lequel madame le
rapporteur a sollicité l'avis du
gouvernement c'est un avis défavorable
pour trois raisons d'abord nous sommes
sur une prime de partage de la valeur et
dès lors que votre amendement concerne
les particuliers employeurs dans une
relation avec des salariés à domicile la
notion de partage de la valeur perd un
peu de sens il ira ensuite un principe
que nous reproduisons peut-être que vous
le contesterait qui est que la prime
exceptionnelle de pouvoir d'achat tel
qu'il a été défini depuis 2010 9 n'a
jamais été ouverte aux particuliers
employeurs et enfin les mêmes
particuliers employeurs bénéficient sur
l'intégralité des versements qu'ils font
auprès de leurs salariés à domicile d'un
crédit d'impôt égal à 50% de la somme et
donc ajouter des exonérations comme vous
le proposez sera ajoutée à un principe
qui est déjà extrêmement protecteur est
favorable aux particuliers employeurs
donc pour ces trois raisons
l'avis est défavorable le 322 de madame
mange lavier est défavorable le 34 de
madame delattre je considère qu'il est
satisfait pour la partie apprentis c'est
une demande de retrait ou à défaut un
avis défavorable les 398 de madame
paolig agen qui modifie le seuil à 2000
euros c'est défavorable le 251 de
monsieur mais non ville qui permet de
décider de plusieurs primes dans l'année
défavorable le 149 de madame de madame
apourceau poly c'est défavorable puisque
c'est une modification du plafond le 42e
de monsieur canevet défavorable pour les
mêmes raisons que madame le rapporteur
pour le 90 de madame humbert
contrairement à madame la rapporteure
l'avis est défavorable pour une raison
en particulier vous proposait
d'appliquer des taux de l'entreprise
utilisatrice plutôt que de l'entreprise
de travail temporaire or l'intégralité
des exonérations cotisations calcul du
crédit d'impôt dispositif d'intervention
de l'état concernant les travailleurs
intérimaires a toujours été fondée sur
la taille et la situation de
l'entreprise de travail intérimaire et
non pas de l'entreprise utilisatrice et
ouvrir une brèche à l'occasion de cette
prime de partage de la valeur amènerait
à réinterroger les modalités de calcul
de l'intégralité dès dispositions
non plus en fonction de l'entreprise de
travail temporaire mais en fonction de
l'entreprise utilisatrice donc chez
défavorable pour cette raison là le 151
le 150-200 53 défavorables pour les
mêmes raisons que madame le rapporteur
pour le 250 de kate une suppression de
conditions d'intéressement défavorable
de la même manière pour le 380 de
monsieur delcros je partage le même avis
que madame le rapporteur pour le 23 de
madame la varde c'est opérationnellement
nous ne savons pas faire y compris
d'ailleurs en termes de transmission
d'informations même si l'intention peut
être partagé nous ne pouvons pas le
mettre en oeuvre d'où l'avis défavorable
sur l'amendement rédactionnelle de
madame le rapporteur c'est favorable le
123 de madame mange c'est défavorable
252 monsieur lennon ville c'est
défavorable et le sens de madame paoli
gajan défavorable pour les derniers pour
les mêmes raisons que madame le
rapporteur
très bien monsieur le ministre avant de
demander les explications de vote juste
je me tourne vers la commission adam la
rapporteure vous demandiez l'avis du
gouvernement sur le 137 qui est un avis
défavorable ça veut dire que quelle
serait la ville la commission
vous suivait l'avis du ministre donc des
savoirs merci alors j'ai déjà un certain
nombre d'inscrits qui souhaitent des
explications de vote lever la main
la varde aussi rajouté l'aveyron
pas de regret à l'est pardon
on y va madame là
c'est le clos on y va madame la
présidente rossignol
mon explication de vote va porter à la
fois sur l'amendement de madame du bain
le 359 et va donner notre point de vue
sur les autres amendements l'amendement
déposé par notre collègue du ballroom
socialiste temps à soumettre cette
fameuse prime allant madame la
rapporteure je comprends que vous
trouviez que le mot prime macron est
abusif oui prime de partage de la valeur
me paraît aussi un peu abusif
différemment mais on le partage n'est
pas garanti dans cette affaire peut-être
on aurait pu l'appeler libéralités
exonéré de cotisations sociales et
n'ouvrant aucun droit ni à la retraite
complémentaire ni la retraite de base le
chômage c'était un peu long mais on
aurait bien trouver un acronyme pour la
qualifier je voulais simplement dire que
pour nous cette prime cette nouvelle
prime c'est la prolongation et
l'extension en volume de pâques de la
prime précédente est un coup de
pelleteuse supplémentaires dans d'autres
dispositifs de protection sociale et
dans le l'histoire de la protection
sociale en france parce que l'article
242 1 du code de la sécurité sociale qui
prévoit que toute somme versée en
contrepartie ou à l'occasion du travail
donne lieu à cotisations sociales est le
fondement même et du droit du travail et
du droit de la sécurité sociale c'est à
partir de cet article qui a été créé
pour que justement les employeurs
soumettent bien toutes les sommes à la
cyclo sociale et ne donne pas des gages
comme ça des petites des petits
arrangements avec les salariés pour
justement échappé à notre dispositif et
de solidarité collective et vous venez
une fois de plus avec ce dispositif
donner un coup supplémentaire alors j'en
comprends bien la logique la logique
elle est à la fois d'exonérer au maximum
le travail de sa contribution à la
protection sociale de réduire le salaire
des salariés parce que le salaire de
base plus haut salaire différé forme le
salaire et il va falloir aussi que vous
expliquez que toutes ces sommes ne
seront pas accordés à tous les salariés
loin de là qu'elles défendront cas
dépendre du bon vouloir de l'employeur
et qu'elles n'ouvrent ont aucun droit et
nous de votre os nous donc nous pensons
que ce n'est pas réformable au delà de
ce que je viens de dire c'est pourquoi
nous abstiendrons sur l'ensemble des
amendements même si je comprends que mes
collègues et tenter de faire mieux avec
ce qui était pas terrible merci madame
cohen
oui on voit bien qu'avec avec cet
article c'est une logique et ce sont
deux logiques qui s'affrontent
on est en fait façade à deux projets de
société qui sont complètement différents
et on a on a essayé en tout cas nous sur
les bancs du groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologistes malgré
notre désaccord profond sur la logique
des primes avec les exonérations et si
quand même d'un d'atténuer les
conséquences et notamment au moins de
mettre des conditionnalités et moi je
suis quand même extrêmement choqué par
le fait qu' ici ça n'a pas l'air de
déranger la majorité du gouvernement que
d'accorder effectivement un certain
nombre davantage et le mot est
minimaliste sans aucune contrepartie
c'est à dire c'est vraiment au bon
vouloir des entreprises sans
conditionnalité pour la majorité d'entre
nous ici mes chers collègues nous avons
eu des unes et nous avons même encore un
certain nombre d'autres mandats locaux
que ce soit au niveau municipal au
niveau des conseils départementaux
niveau des conseils régionaux jamais
dans ces collectivités en tout cas à ma
connaissance j'étais moi-même longtemps
conseillère régionale nous avons accordé
des aides à des entreprises ou sans
conditionnalité je pense notamment à
l'île de france mais à toutes les
régions d ici pas de problème et quand
on essaye de dire mais au moins essayons
un peu de limiter la casse et par
exemple sur un amendement comme qui nous
tient à coeur sur l'égalité salariale
entre les femmes et les hommes essayons
un peu de donner des conditionnalités ah
non surtout pas on va brimer fille et
j'entends madame la rapporteure dire on
va brimés
finalement on va désavantager les
salariés mais alors mes chers collègues
comme dirait cathy apourceau poly si
vous voulez pas désavantager les
salariés augmenter le smic augmenté les
salaires c'est la meilleure la meilleure
solution c'est ce que je voulais dire
dans les explications de vote et je suis
très choquée effectivement par ce
laxisme
c'est madame grès hommes
moi je vais revenir sur l'amendement 153
qui propose d'exclure du bénéfice des
exonérations des cotisations sociales
les entreprises ou les contrats à temps
partiel qui dépasse 20% de la masse
salariale totale vous avez bien compris
cet amendement c'est pour encourager les
entreprises à recruter à temps complet
monsieur le ministre madame la
rapporteure mais jacques collègues je
crois qu'on ne vit pas dans le même
monde
parce qu'aujourd'hui peut-être qu'il ya
des personnes qui sont intéressées par
le temps partiel mais je pense qu'on
devrait avoir un véritable débat parce
qu'aujourd'hui moi je connais beaucoup
de gens aussi en leur proposant un
contrat à temps partiel eh ben ils
calculent ils calculent s'ils sont
gagnants d'aller travailler ou pas alors
je pense qu'il faudrait à jour en
discute et clairement tout le monde
ensemble on est un véritable débat sur
le sujet les gens ont besoin d'un temps
complet c'est normal qu'ils ont temps
complet c'est à deux voies que la france
a vis-à-vis d'eux voilà merci madame la
présidente de l'autre
merci monsieur le président pour mon
amendement effectivement il ya une
demande une double demande de retrait je
comprends complètement ce que a expliqué
madame le rapporteur sur la
différenciation apprentis et stagiaires
donc effectivement j'accepte sa remarque
et dont je retire puisque pour
l'apprentissage ce qui était plus
important il est il est satisfait donc
merci
merci la présidente madame la
rapporteure labarde oui merci alors je
vais faire les deux amendements en même
temps sur la complexité de l'amendement
numéro 23 je me dis qu'heureusement
finalement une nouvelle mesure a été
trouvé pour le soutien du carburant
puisque j'en avais comme une usine c'est
un peu la même chose qui avait été
déposé dans le texte initial du
gouvernement
voilà je ferme cette parenté sur ce
sujet mais c'est dommage parce qu'on
aurait pu ici avoir une vraie mesure de
pouvoir d'achat pour des ménages dans
lequel le salarié aisés et celui qui à
3,1 smic est donc là on aurait une prime
qui aurait été défiscalisée pour
l'ensemble du ménage sur l'amendement
donc je vais le retirer puisque
j'entends que c'est la complexité et sur
le premier amendement le 22 autant quand
la rapporteure me dis il n'y a pas de
liquidités est allé dans le vide et
qu'on espère une prime de pouvoir
d'achat j'entends cet argument vous
monsieur le ministre vous souhaitez
rétablir la prime de partage de la
valeur j'ai expliqué ce matin à la
tribune que je redis on était dans un
choc d'offre est donc à mettre des
liquidités sur le marché vient auto
entretenir cette inflation donc là ce
que j'essaie de vous dire c'est qu'il ya
un certain nombre des bénéficiaires de
la prime qui ne vont pas fort qui n'ont
pas un besoin immédiat de liquidités
mais pour lequel en fait leur permettre
de pouvoir investir cette prime en
complément d'intéressement leur permet
de préserver leur pouvoir d'achat sur le
long terme puisque dans un contexte
d'inflation et de beaucoup plus au
regard de placer sur des produits
d'épargné préserve beaucoup plus le
niveau que d'avoir sur un compte courant
donc j'avoue que j'ai du mal à
comprendre pourquoi vous est défavorable
à cet amendement il est maintenu il est
maintenu alors je retire le 23 qu'ils
étaient trop complexes et je maintiens
le 22e parce que j'ai du mal à
comprendre en fait la position du visage
en temps celui et celle de la commission
ce qui est logique avec le changement de
terme de la prime est ce qu'il n'est pas
dans avec très bien monsieur guay
merci merci merci monsieur le président
sur le ministre mes chers collègues je
vais écouter tous les amendements
notamment ceux qui nous propose par
exemple de pouvoir épargner de pouvoir
décaler le mois où l'on m'a touché la
prime de pouvoir même le fractionné en
trois ou quatre mais je rappelle que 84
% des salariés ont touché 0 donc vous
pouvez fractionné ou la touche et quatre
fois mais quatre fois 0 à la fin à la
fin ça fait zéro donc je vous repose la
question basque y compris madame la
rapporteure et je vous remercie pour
l'ensemble des explications que vous
avez donnée assez précises à chaque
amendement est un moment vous avez une
phrase qui vous a échappé vous avez dit
en espérant que les salariés touchent
est pris et s'est pris c'est presque un
voeu pieux donc moi je redis qu'est ce
que nous faisons pour les 84 % des
salariés qu'on pas toucher la prime
quelle est la solution que nous
proposons est pour l'instant la réponse
du gouvernement sait rien
parce que vous pouvez triplé plafond
d'ailleurs il ya 15 % des salariés ont
touché les 1000 euros et je me rappelle
très bien que le ministre bruno le maire
nous avait expliqué aux sorcières du
confinement qui avaient des petits
salaires notamment des très bas salaires
notamment dans la grande distribution
vous il y avait beaucoup de métiers
féminins et nous avait dit là il faut y
aller sur la prime macro et quand on est
retourné voir
les ouvrières et les ouvriers notamment
la grande distribution personne n'a
touché la prime à 1000 euros personne à
1000 euros et quand on discute avec eux
ça a été très aléatoire donc vous avez
un problème rien ne sera réglé avec cet
article qu'est ce que vous proposez pour
84 % des salariés qui ne touchent rien
et donc après on peut avoir le débat
est-ce qu'il faut l'appeler la prime
maquereau ou la prime de partage de la
valeur 84 % des salariés la touche trop
toujours pas c'est monsieur bako
merci monsieur le président de nombreux
amendements divers et variés étaient
présentes et moi permettez-moi de
revenir sur la philosophie de la prime
alors comme l'a bien dit monsieur guay
comme elle touchera un nombre limité de
personnes vouloir paraît cette prime
d'une vertu de hausse globale du pouvoir
d'achat des françaises c'est un mensonge
mais c'est pas pour autant c'est pas
pour autant qu'il faut se priver de ce
dispositif qui a des vertus
et très concrètement faut voir d'où on
vient c'est à dire avant 2020 avant la
fameuse prime comme l'a très bien dit
fred puis ça un justement abusivement
appelée macron ce qui se passait
auparavant c'est qu'il y avait des
possibilités de primes mais très
compliqué et le ministre du soft pourra
peut-être nous le confirmer avant 2020
lorsqu'un chef d'entreprise dont
l'entreprise n'était pas dans les
dispositifs d'intéressement ou de
participation à ce qu'il voulait donner
une prime de 1000 euros justement ça
coûte l entreprise 1820 euros donc alors
là c'était pas 1% de salariés qui ont
bénéficié de la prime c'était du 0,002 %
c'était ridicule et donc le fait de
défiscaliser de décharger cette prime
permet
à un nombre qui n'est pas si ridicule
que ça de salariés d'en bénéficier
néanmoins donc c'est une mesure que je
voterai globalement mais faut quand même
savoir d'où l'on vient
c'est une mesure positive mais c'est pas
ça qui améliorera le pouvoir d'achat
global des français ne jetons donc pas
la prime avec l'eau de la propagande
médiatique gouvernementale mais c'est
quand même mieux que rien
écoutez vous les uns les autres je pense
que certains orateurs s'exprime dans le
silence des autres il n'y a pas de
raison que ça se fasse pas de l'autre
côté
monsieur assouline
et
je me suis souvenu de quelque chose
parce que quand on allait devant les
électeurs tout le monde voyait qu'il y
avait un sujet majeur pas seulement de
pouvoir d'achat en général mais de
salaire et je me souviens de la mesure
phare de madame pécresse souvenez vous
avez déjà oublié peut-être c'était 10 %
d'augmentation des salaires n'étaient
pas les primes et tout ça alors bien sûr
il y avait la politique de exonérations
de charge du patronat pas de charges
sociales de 2,2 d'impôt de production
etc mais globalement c'est ça que vous
avez défendu par la majorité sénatoriale
pendant des mois
comme votre proposition parce que devant
les électeurs vous ne pouviez pas tenir
à notre propos maintenant vous êtes en
train de faire un accord avec le
gouvernement
sur quelque chose qui
vient compte revenir y compris avec ce
que vous avez à séné souvent comme
idéologie dans ce débat sur le travail
vous avez souvent montré ce qu'ils n'ont
pas justement de travail et donc ne
peuvent pas avoir de salaire et donc
vivre de prestations sociales comme des
assistés
bien là vous voulez maintenant de
l'assistanat pour les salariés oui la
prime c'est quoi c'est pas reconnaître
le travail et donc le salaire qui va
avec et donc le salaire dans sa
globalité c'est une aide ponctuelle
parce qu'il ya un problème de pouvoir
d'achat qui est à la discrétion qui est
une une aumône ça a été dit par d'autres
ici et puis une deuxième contradiction
ou là vous faites payer deux fois vous
êtes pour l'augmentation de l'âge de la
retraite
vous dites pour cela que c'est parce que
il n'ya pas assez d'argent dans les
caisses mais avec ses primes c'est de
l'argent encore en moins dans les
caisses par contre les salariés vont
payer deux fois parce que ces salariés
eux ne vont pas pouvoir compter sur leur
cotisation et sur leur leur retraite à
la fin de leur carrière si monsieur les
lyonnais en primaire donc voilà cette
injustice la 1ère si vous la partagez
accueilli un euro
ça concerne l'amendement 137 monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre vous avez
avancé quelques arguments j'entends
celui de la réduction
d'impôt de 50 % j'ai plus de mal à
entendre la notion de création de valeur
parce qu'il me semble que quand il y a
un travail même quand c'est un travail à
domicile qui concerne les salariés à
domicile eahd création de valeur c'est
la notion même de de valeur et
deuxièmement vous avez dit tout à
l'heure à madame de lattes que c'était
le contrat de travail qui ouvrait droit
à prime or là
il y a aussi un contrat de travail et
donc c'est un peu contradictoire dès que
l'argumentation que vous avez avancé
adam delattre tout à l'heure je vous
remercie d'avoir ses explications et cet
éclairage même si je n'ai pas d
illusions démesurée sur le sort de mon
amendement merci les mains de monsieur
et nous mais il est maintenant merci
dernière oratrice madame jasmin
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
ministre quand vous l'avez constaté tout
ce qui a été dit là ne s'applique pas
forcément sur nos territoires
d'outre-mer alors comment imaginer que
l'approvisionnement pour le pit se fait
en mer du nord vaut les antilles alors
que en amérique du sud et
particulièrement dans les zones
limitrophes de la guyane on a la
possibilité d'avoir moins cher pour nos
territoires et ça pourrait permettre de
réduire évidemment les coûts sur nos
territoires
merci beaucoup bien alors chacun va
essayer de rester un peu silencieux
parce que ça va aller assez vite qui a
27 enfin un peu moyen à 2 de retirer
donc nous allons voter 25 à maintenant
merci de suivre le 359
avis négatif de la commission
négatif du gouvernement qu'est pour
merci qui est contre
il est rejeté le 257
avis négatif de la commission et du
gouvernement et ce sont les mêmes 257
369 3 180 pieds pour
d'accord
qui est contre bon allez qui s'abstient
madame rossignol vous nous aviez dit que
vous abstenez sur tous les amendements
mais pas sur celui-là
bon
oui oui je ne sais pas le sujet bon en
tout cas ils sont rejetés aller
le 114 deux avis défavorables qui est
pour
[Musique]
et contre qui s'abstient
il est rejeté le 453 c'est l'amendement
du gouvernement avec un avis défavorable
de la commission qui et pour
qui est en train
qui s'abstient il est rejeté le 22
de la commission des finances qui est
maintenu celui là
deux avis défavorables commission
gouvernement qui est pour
et qui est contre
il est resté aussi membre de la
commission des finances mais de votre
peau le 102 identique le sang et le 404
deux avis favorables
est ce que le gouvernement lève le gage
sur ces deux amendements identiques le
gage lv2 avis favorable qu'est pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient ils sont adoptés le 137
deux avis défavorables qui et pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient il est rejeté le 322 deux
avis défavorables qui pour
qui et contre
rejeté
le 30 4 et retirer le 398 deux avis
défavorables quai pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient il est rejeté le 251 deux
avis défavorables quai pour
bon pardon
l'essentiel c'est que vous écoutiez moi
aller le 251 gens recommencent deux avis
défavorables qui pour
qui est contre il est rejeté le 149,2
avis défavorable qui est pour
et qui est contre
[Musique]
il est rejeté le 42 deux avis
défavorables qui est pour
et qui est contre
il est rejeté
le 90 avis favorable de la commission
défavorable du gouvernement qui est pour
alors la levée bien la main on va
compter
qui est contre
qui s'abstient
il est adopté le 151 deux avis
défavorables qui est pour
et qui est contre
projeté le 152 deux avis défavorables
qui pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient projeté le 153 deux avis
défavorables qui et pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient rejeté le 250 de deux
avis défavorables qui pour
seulement vivre et qui est contre
il est rejeté le 380 deux avis
défavorables qui et pour
qui compte il est rejeté le 23 et
retirer le 444 deux avis favorable
qu'est pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient il est adopté le 123 deux
avis défavorables qui et pour
[Musique]
qui et contre
acheter le 250 deux avis défavorables
qui est pour
et qui est contre
projeté le 101 deux avis défavorables
qui est pour
et qui est contre
rejeté merci nous en avons fini avec
cette liasse
toujours à l'article 1er madame la
rapporteure le 443 au nom de la
commission
coordination du président à vie du
gouvernement favorable le 443
coordination qui est pour
et qui est contre
il est adopté le 8
monsieur michaud
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre puisque le gouvernement et la
majorité présidentielle non la majorité
sénatoriale n'ont pas voulu augmenter le
smic cet amendement vise à compenser la
perte de recettes pour la sécurité
sociale et l'état générés par l'article
1er du projet de loi par une sur
imposition des bénéfices des grands
groupes en effet si l'intention du
gouvernement d'augmenter le pouvoir
d'achat des salariés est louable sa
proposition créer un manque à gagner
pour les organismes de sécurité sociale
tant il est prouvé que ces dispositifs
de primes et d'intéressement
ce substitut de fait dans un certain
nombre d'entreprises à la rémunération
de base or le gouvernement ne propose
pas de compenser ce manque à gagner
alors que la sécurité sociale a
enregistré en 2021 un déficit de 31,2
milliards d'euros à l'opposé de cette
logique d'approvisionnement de la
sécurité sociale qui est malheureusement
la première étape vers la dégradation
des droits sociaux il est proposé par
cet amendement que les entreprises qui
ont réalisé des super profits et qui
réalise un chiffre d'affaires supérieur
à 1 milliard d'euros soit mise à
contribution
merci à vis de la commission madame le
rapporteur présidente donc c'est un avis
défavorable 1 je rappelle que niveau de
rémunération et comme secrétaire un
élément possible mais qui n'est pas
obligatoire or cet amendement visera le
rendre obligatoire il complice qu'il
complexifierait la prime est donc c'est
un avis défavorable pour cela merci
avait du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
merci monsieur le président je crains
que monsieur le sénateur et défendre un
autre amendement que celui qui dans le
dérouleur ce que vous l'amendement
numéro heat n'a absolument rien à voir
avec les super profits la taxation
est oui
le problème c'est que je ne peux pas
vous redonner la parole donc on vote
l'amendement tel quel
sur le 8 avec deux avis négatifs qui est
pauvre
à voter sur l'amendement lui-même pas
sur l'explication de vote requis contre
qui s'abstient
il est rejeté quatre amendements
identiques
d'abord le 45 qui le défend
madame chauvin vous battez pas madame
chauvin alesi
donc cet amendement a pour objectif
d'ajouter un critère de performance
individuelle aux quatre critères déjà
prévues par le projet de loi afin
d'attribuer la prime partage de la
valeur de manière justifiée et
différenciés aux salariés d'une même
entreprise cela permettra de récompenser
les salariés les plus investis au sein
de cette entreprise
madame mercier le 249 identiques qui le
défend mieux la gourde
défendu il est défendu merci le 373
madame l'abrasion billon
merci monsieur le
président il est bien entendu défendu il
est question de rémunérer mieux le
travail de revaloriser le travail donc
comme j'ai bien entendu ce matin lors de
la discussion générale il était question
dans nos objectifs pour un certain
nombre d'adorateurs de mieux rémunérer
le travail donc je ne je ne présage pas
de la de la suite sur cet amendement
mais je pense qu'il est tout à fait
cohérent par rapport à ce qui a été dit
ce matin par un certain nombre
d'orateurs merci r c'est le 304e 22 qui
le défend
jeu des traînes
c'est un amendement qui vise à permettre
aux employeurs des tpe de bénéficier de
plus de flexibilité quant au versement
de la prime du partage de la valeur le
mode de fonctionnement des tpe est loin
d'être hall celui des pme où tu es rendu
quand grandes entreprises du fait du
très petit nombre de salariés il semble
opportun que le chef d'entreprise
puissent a dit visualiser le versement
de la prime à ce titre en intégrant la
le critère de performance individuelle
aux quatre autres prévues par la loi
cette prime pourrait récompenser un ou
plusieurs salariés en particulier
ses avis de la commission sur ces quatre
amendements identiques je comprends
l'enjeu est de la performance
individuelle individuel je considère
quand même qu'il y à d'autres outils
pour ce faire les outils que sont à
minima le salaire et les primes de
performance donc c'est plutôt un avis
défavorable je ne crois ne pas être
suivi vu le nombre d'amendements dans
tout cas je maintiens l'avis défavorable
qui suit la commission avait du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président la loi
prévoit effectivement le projet de loi
prévoit de pouvoir prendre en compte la
classification le niveau de rémunération
l'ancienneté et la durée de présence
effective dans l'entreprise comme
critère de modulation de la prime les
amendements défendus à l'instant font de
la performance individuelle un nouveau
critère nous considérons que c'est une
prime de partage de la valeur de
d'association des salariés à la richesse
produite par les entreprises
lorsqu'elles peut le faire et cela était
passé de le verser est pas un outil de
reconnaissance de la performance
individuelle pour ça il ya des primes de
performance modem le rapporteur l'a dit
il ya aussi des modulations salariale et
donc un avis défavorable pour garder à
ce dispositif son caractère initial bien
je vais me yeux mouillés
présente quelques mots
j'entends les différents arguments
proposés par nos collègues qui portent
ces amendements mais depuis depuis tout
à l'heure on se plaint d'un côté qu' il
n'y a pas suffisamment d'accès pour les
salariés à la prime de l'autre côté on
évoque ne sont de simplification pour
les entreprises et là on entend de
proposer quatre amendements qui viennent
complicité de système alors on comprend
la motivation comprend la notion de
priorité mais aujourd'hui tout ce que
l'on veut c'est faire en sorte que le
plus grand nombre de salariés puissent
bénéficier d'une prime donnée
saint-charles entreprises entrent déjà
des critères proposés par le
gouvernement le critère du premier
amendement du deuxième amendement du 3
un amendement du quatrième amendement
que vous êtes sûr qu'il ya des chefs
d'entreprise métro saddat leurs tiroirs
et il y aura encore des résultats qui
sont mauvais pour la prime est attribuée
rendez vous compte de ce que vous
proposez
merci je mets aux voix c'est quatre
amendements identiques avec deux avis
défavorables qui pour
wii et contre
ils sont rejetés chez maintenant 35
madame la présidente de lattre oui merci
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues aux termes de l'alinéa 7 de
l'article 1er le montant de la prime de
pouvoir d'achat peut différer selon les
bénéficiaires en fonction de la
rémunération du niveau de classification
de l'ancienneté dans l'entreprise de la
durée de présence effective pendant
l'année écoulée ou de la durée de
travail prévue au contrat de travail
comme nous l'a indiqué philippe mouiller
ses critères de modulation sont
importants puisqu'ils permettent
néanmoins d'adapter de manière
suffisamment fine le dispositif à la
situation du bénéficiaire et son
implication au sein de l'entreprise vous
le savez j'ai soutenu l'ouverture de
cette prime à d'autres types de contrat
et je pense que nous devons aller plus
loin sur la question des personnes en
situation d'insertion pour permettre de
valoriser au mieux leurs parcours et
leurs efforts l'objectif du gouvernement
qui est notre objectif à tous est celui
du plein emploi le plein emploi parce
par des dispositifs incitatifs des
dispositifs qui embarque aussi dans le
retour à l'emploi je veux saluer ici le
travail formidable menée par les maisons
de l'emploi les prix et toutes les
entreprises qui jouent le jeu de
l'insertion avec lesquels j'ai co
construit cet amendement cet amendement
a donc pour objectif de majorer la prime
de pouvoir d'achat pour les personnes en
insertion depuis moins de cinq ans un
encouragement à ne pas rater me
semble-t-il merci see avis de la
commission madame la rapporteure c'est
vrai madame madame la présidente que ce
c est un moment un peu compliqué aussi
je dois dire que du coup c'est un avis
défavorable à ce titre là néanmoins je
porte quand vous une attention très
particulière aux structures d'insertion
par l'activité économique
je peux en entendre la philosophie mais
qui sait peut-être sur un autre
dispositif que cet amendement pourra
trouver sa raison d'être donc avis
défavorable de la commission
gouvernement mais ma vie
je mets aux voileux 35 deux avis
défavorables qui est pour
et qui est contre
il est rejeté le 316 madame poncet mange
merci monsieur le président
mes chers collègues cet amendement de ma
collègue écologiste mélanie vogel vise à
lutter contre les inégalités de genre au
sein de l'entreprise les familles sont
en effet souvent dans une situation
économique précaire alors même que les
métiers précarisés où elles sont
majoritaires sont essentiels à notre
société les dynamiques sont bien
documentés par les sciences humaines
l'assignation des femmes à la sphère
domestique et au travail non rémunéré
participe largement au fait que les
réseaux de pouvoir sont historiquement
quasi exclusivement masculin et à ce
qu'on appelle désormais le plafond de
verre mais il existe aussi un effet
planché collants qui existe des
l'embauchent les cas constatés des
rémunérations à l'embauché maintien de
dents durant le parcours il suit la
salariée au fil du parcours
professionnel que ce soit lors des
augmentations générales de salaire ou
individuels des promotions et des
montées en responsabilité s'ajoute enfin
ça a été évoqué déjà les trappes à temps
partiel et à bas salaires qui
accroîtront les quarts en l'absence de
dispositions spécifiques la prime
mentionné à cet article ne re remédiera
pas et voir aggravera les inégalités de
genre ainsi selon l'insee je rappelle
les femmes occupent 79 % des emplois à
temps partiel souvent subi 70% des
emplois à bas salaires 59 % des emplois
payés au smic qu'on n'a pas voulu
revaloriser l'insee nous rappelle
également que dans 82% des familles
monoparentales ce sont les maires qui
ont qui ont la charge leur situation est
en moyenne très précaire alors que la
forte inflation des derniers mois
renforce des situations de pauvreté
c'est pourquoi cet amendement vise à
s'assurer que la prime de partage de la
valeur n'aggrave pas les inégalités
salariales
selon le genre au sein des entreprises
et renforce de manière plus égalitaire
le pouvoir d'achat des salariés
concernés
merci à vis de la commission monsieur
président donc c'est un amendement qui
vise à une interdiction de verser un
montant moyen de primes inférieures aux
femmes par rapport aux hommes ça rend
effectivement cette prime très rigide
c'est pas l'esprit de cette prime et
c'est pas celui qui a prévalu dans nos
travaux donc c'est à ce titre là un avis
défavorable non
défavorable pour les mêmes raisons mais
j'ajoute une précision comme je lé fais
l'assemblée si un employeur retenez le
genre comme un élément de ré de
détermination et donc de modulation de
la prime ce serait illégal nous avons
quatre critères que j'ai rappelé tout à
l'heure il est absolument hors de
question dans un sens comme dans l'autre
que le jard soit un critère modulation
de la prime mais hall au delà pour la
complexité rappelé madame amara porter
défavorable
je me revois le 316 avec deux avis
défavorables gay pour
des contres qui s'abstient il est rejeté
le 245 monsieur lagourgue
tel que rédigé un employeur ne pourrait
jamais supprimer une prime ce qui serait
un non sens le présent amendement
prévoit donc que la substitution joue
dès lors que les demandes salaire est
supprimée avant l'attribution de la
prime de partage
et avis de la commission mananara porter
c'était un abandon un peu compliqué je
veux dire qu'on y rester un petit moment
pour bien le comprendre mais en tout cas
on pense que c'est un amendement qui est
presque satisfait sachant que la prime
peut être ou ne pas être versée donc
c'est un avis défavorable mais peut-être
que que le sens nous a un peu échappé en
tout cas c'est défavorable au niveau la
commission avait des gouvernements
les défavorables aussi je pense même que
l'objectif des auteurs mais ne
correspond pas à la rédaction avec là
avec ce que vous proposez vous dit pas
de substitution si la prime remplacer a
été décidé avant le versement de la
prime est en réalité il suffirait dans
le pire des cas qu'un employeur supprime
un élément de rémunération sous forme de
primes aux mois de février et qu'il
décide d'attribuer une prime de partage
de la valeur mois d'avril pour qui les
effets de substitution vous voulez
éviter donc au delà de ce que dit madame
le rapporteur c'est défavorable ou voir
demande de retrait
il est retiré merci monsieur lagourgue
le 30 sept oui ce cabanel merci monsieur
le président dans ce projet de loi pour
le pouvoir d'achat l'un des axes
concernent la protection du niveau de
vie des français le ministre de
l'économie a rappelé que notre priorité
de protéger économiquement les français
or nous savons bien la hausse des prix
frappe davantage les français
défavorisés donc évidemment les bas
salaires c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous proposons de prioriser pour le
versement de la prime de partage de la
valeur donc pour plus de pouvoir d'achat
les salariés dont les revenus sont les
plus modestes davantage exposées aux
hausses de prix
et la commission donc cet amendement
comme le précédent en viserait à ce que
la rémunération qui est déjà un critère
soit un critère obligatoire les noms
possibles donc sa régie dix filles aussi
ce système de primes donc son avis
défavorable gouvernement même avis le 37
deux avis négatifs qui est pur il est
retiré il est retiré merci monsieur
cabanel le 89 madame de seine
monde ment merci est le pendant de celui
qui a été adoptée précédemment il
précise que la prime de partage versé
par une entreprise de travail temporaire
est réservé aux seuls salariés
permanents de cette entreprise merci à
vis de la commission écoutez là aussi
c'est un avis favorable alors je sais
que monsieur le ministre tout à l'heure
a dit que ce n'était pas un sujet pour
nous c'est un vrai sujet on a un sujet
sur le travail par intérim donc je
propose de donner un avis favorable
c'est ce que la commission a fait tout à
l'heure à cet amendement et si besoin on
en rediscute en séance parce que je
crois qu'on aura sinon avec une
entreprise de travail temporaire des
vrais sujets de crispation sociale et
c'est pas l'objectif je pense qu'ils du
gouvernement ni le nôtre donc c'est un
avis favorable à cet amendement
gouvernement merci monsieur le président
je comprends l'amendement puisque tout à
l'heure le sénat a voté le fait que la
prime était versée aux salariés
intérimaires en fonction des conditions
de l'entreprise utilisatrice et pas de
l'entreprise de travail temporaire et du
coup vous réservez la prime versée par
les entreprises de travail temporaire
alors personnel permanent et non pas aux
intérimaires il ya une logique l'avis du
gouvernement restent défavorables non
pas que nous considérions que ça n'est
pas un sujet comme le dit madame
rapporteur mais parce que toutes les
conditions de calcul d'exonération de
défiscalisation d'encadrement des
disques salariaux extra salariaux des
salariés intérimaires sont calculés sur
des conditions de l'entreprise de
travail temporaire et le fait d'ouvrir
un système dérogatoire avec la prime
comme le sénat l'a voté des quelques
instants nous paraît dangereux parce que
ça ne paraît créer un précédent donc ça
reste défavorable et comme me l'a dit
madame la rapporteure nous aurons
l'occasion d'ici là la première cmp
peut-être en mode lecture de continuer à
travailler sur le sujet très bien je
mets aux voileux 89 avec un avis
favorable de la commission
défavorable du gouvernement qui et pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient il est adopté
deux amendements discussion commune le
150 monsieur guay merci monsieur le
président celui nice paix chers
collègues c'est un amendement pour
supprimer le fractionnement de la prime
de pouvoir d'achat est en réalité c'est
un amendement de cohérence
je vais citer l'excellent rapport pour
avis de la commission des finances du
sénat
s'il expressément prévu que la prime de
partage de la valeur ne puisse se
substituer à aucun des éléments de
rémunération
ces dispositions relèvent davantage
d'une déclaration d'intention dépourvu
d'une réelle portée normative
il serait par ailleurs impossible
d'aller vérifier à l'occasion de chacun
des versements que la prime respecte
bien cette condition de non substitution
si il y à fractionner et donc je vous le
dis je pense qu'il faut se mettre en
accord avec ce que le rapport pour avis
de la commission des finances d'autant
plus que j'entends beaucoup qu'il faut
évidemment alléger les contraintes des
entreprises
s'il y avait fractionnement par exemple
en quatre vous savez comme il existe
aujourd'hui de primes donc il ya la
prime de partage de la valeur au prix
macron la prime exceptionnelle de
pouvoir d'achat la prime d'ancienneté la
prime de 13ème mois la prime pour
l'emploi et même il en existe une une
prime pour les conditions de travail
donc il ya six voire sept prime s'il
faut les fractionner en quatre imaginez
le travail que ça représente pour les
entreprises d'ailleurs je pense qu'on
devrait supprimer toutes ces primes ce
qui serait plus simple ce qu'on verse du
salaire aux salariés
merci avis de la commission sur à part
d'autre part d'avoir une discussion
commune le 119 d'imposer mange
merci monsieur président depuis de trop
nombreuses années les grands groupes
bénéficient dette publique considérable
selon l'observatoire des multinationales
en 2020 100 % des entreprises du cac 40
ont bénéficié des aides publiques de
l'état et 80% d'entre elles dans le même
temps ont eu recours fortement au
chômage partiel en 2021 le cac40
engendrait 130 milliards d'euros de
bénéfices un record historique qui a
permis le versement de manière agrégée
de 51 milliards d'euros de dividendes
ces entreprises ont elles réellement
besoin d'être exonéré de cotisations
sociales et fiscales pour verser des
primes quand allez vous ciblez quand
allez vous conditionner les aides vous
qui causent visionner vous qui
conditionné et contrôler le moindre euro
de prestations sociales les politiques
d'exonération contribuer à normaliser
les stratégies d'évitement fiscal et la
tendance à ne pas prendre sa part à la
solidarité nationale elles devraient
être ciblées et ne devenir incitatives
qu'en direction des petites et moyennes
entreprises un hors jeu important
puisque selon l'insee seulement 17 % des
tpe au verset une paie pas pour
seulement 15 % de leurs salariés
là où 58% des entreprises de plus de
1000 aux verser une prime exceptionnelle
de pouvoir d'achat pour 39 % de leurs
salariés les politiques publiques ne
doivent pas avoir comme effet une
disparité manifeste des impacts
bénéfiques en faveur de d'un effet de
taille considérable conduisant à une
concentration des aides sur les plus
grosses entreprises en conséquence notre
amendement vise à limiter les bénéfices
des exonérations de cotisations sociales
aux entreprises de moins de 1000
salariés et c'est déjà une taille fort
forte aux
merci avis de la commission sur ces deux
amendements alors le 150 monsieur le
président en a un qui vise à la
suppression de la possibilité de
fractionner la prime on rappelle bien
que c'est une possibilité c'est pas une
obligation elle répond à une logique de
trésorerie des entreprises donc c'est
une logique et très opérationnel donc
c'est un avis défavorable de la
commission le 119 de même penser manche
qui vient d'être expliqué qui vise à une
limitation des exonérations de
cotisations patronales au titre de la
prime aux seules entreprises de moins de
1000 salariés on considère que dans les
entreprises de plus de 1000 salariés ya
aussi un certain nombre de salariés qui
peuvent avoir besoin de cette prime dans
le cadre des nécessités de pouvoir
d'achat donc c'est un avis défavorable
gouvernement même avis sur les deux jeux
mais aux voileux 150 avec deux avis
défavorables qui pour
tes contre
acheter le 119 deux avis négatifs gay
pour
[Musique]
quiconque
je passe au 99 qui le défend monsieur
lagourgue
après avoir versé au cours de l'année
une prime exceptionnelle de bouvard
d'achat de nombreuses entreprises ont
souhaité compléter ce premier versement
au titre d'un nouvel accord une nouvelle
décision unilatérale de l'employeur tout
en respectant la limite globale du
plafond d'exonération cette possibilité
n'étant pas prévue par des textes
précédents étaient dépourvues de
sécurité juridique le présent amendement
donc pour but de donner une base légale
à cette situation le permettent aux
entreprises qui en ont les moyens et la
volonté de compléter leurs primes
pouvoir d'achat au cours de l'année
civile par une nouvelle décision
unilatérale de l'employeur ou un nouvel
accord d'entreprise dans la limite
globale du plafond applicable et dans le
respect des modalités initiales des
attributions prévues ainsi le cadre
d'unicité de la prime c'est préserver et
commission oui monsieur président leur
déjà tout à l'heure j'ai considéré que
cet amendement 99 était le mien c'est
parce qu'il était bon c'est pour ça mais
c'est pas le mien donc je rend à césar
ce qui appartient à césar et je donne un
avis favorable à cet amendement
d'ailleurs je lui en ai parlé tout à
l'heure quand j'ai parlé de l'amendement
257 369 et 380 qui donnait la
possibilité d'attribution de primes
plusieurs fois dans l'année et là on le
limite à deux fois dans l'année ce qui
me semble être une bonne solution là
aussi qui peut répondre à un certain
nombre d'enjeux de trésorerie donc c'est
un avis favorable
gouvernement monsieur le ministre merci
monsieur le président la vie du
gouvernement est le même quelle que soit
la filiation de l'amendement il est
défavorable j'ai dit tout à l'heure que
le gouvernement est attaché à ce que
cette prime est un caractère
exceptionnel annuel est donc fait
implique qu'il ne soit décidée quand une
fois même si nous considérons que le
fractionnement limité à quatre
versements comme le prévoit un
amendement adopté par la commission est
de bon aloi mais une raison sur une
prime par an dont défavorable je mets
aux voix le 99 avec un avis favorable de
la commission défavorable du
gouvernement qui est pour
[Musique]
et qui est contre
il est adopté le 154 madame apourceau
poly si monsieur le président donc par
cet amendement nous demandons que les
entreprises qui ont versé des dividendes
verse obligatoirement
obligatoirement une prime de partage de
la valeur aux salariés dès lors qu'une
entreprise réalise des bénéfices la
logique de l'économie libéral voudrait
qu'elles partagent les profits avec ses
salariés en premier lieu avant de
distribuer des dividendes aux
actionnaires en 2021 un petit rappel
c'est l'art de la répétition
les entreprises du cac 40 ont versé aux
actionnaires près de 70 milliards
d'euros en dividendes ou en rachat
d'actions soit +2
93% du rap up par rapport à 2020 aucun
salarié n'a vu sa rémunération
progresser dans la même proportion
selon la lettre vernimmen jamais les
restitutions aux actionnaires n'ont été
aussi élevés en valeur absolue depuis
qu'elles sont étudiées en 2003 pour
toutes ces raisons notre amendement vise
à rendre obligatoire le versement de la
prime de partage de la valeur pour les
entreprises qui ont versé des dividendes
je vous remercie merci à vis de la
commission mais dans le rapport c'est un
moment qui vise à une obligation de
verser la prime pour les entreprises
dans leur verser un dividende à ses
actionnaires alors d'une part on régis
d'ifi d'autre part c'est un amendement
qui comporte un risque puisque je
rappelle quand même que les petits
employeurs basse et obligations ça
constitue le versement et du coup leur
rémunération donc je pense que on va
évacuer des petites entreprises avec cet
amendement les salariés qui pour y
travailler et je pense pas que ça soit
l'esprit qui sont recherchés pour tout
ça c'est un avis défavorable
gouvernement même avis le 150 la
tonnelle 958 faces boutique guen ne vous
précipitez pas donc le 154 avec deux
avis négatifs qui est pour
ça peut aider madame apourceau poly
décombres
il est rejeté
cette fois-ci madame cohen le 155 merci
monsieur le président cet amendement est
le pendant l'inversé de notre amendement
154 qui a été rejetée mais peut-être que
dans son cela il vous convaincra
davantage ou et chers collègues en effet
vous avez refusé de soutenir le fait
qu'il ait une obligation de versement de
la prime pour les entreprises qui ont
versé des dividendes soit mais ne pensez
vous pas qu'il faudrait supprimer les
exonérations de cotisations à ces mêmes
entreprises on parle de grandes
entreprises pas de paix m on parle de
toutes ces fortunes à qui la crise a
profité grâce aux aides publiques
perçues le plus souvent un rapport de
l'observatoire des multinationales ça a
été dit mais c'est pédagogique de le
répéter publié en avril 2021 révélait
que les entreprises du cac 40 ont
octroyé plus de 51 milliards d'euros à
leurs actionnaires soit une augmentation
de 22 % par rapport à 2020 pour autant
le résultat net agrégé a chuté de plus
de 55% le rapport montre ainsi que ces
entreprises se sont servis des aides
publiques versées par l'état pour faire
face à la crise sanitaire afin de
rémunérer les actionnaires tout en
supprimant des emplois alors que ces
aides publiques chômage partiel prêts
garantis par l'état reports de
cotisations sociales plan de relance
plans d'urgence ont été accordés sans
aucune conditionnalité ou contrepartie
sociale fiscales environnementales
il est scandaleux que cet argent soit
utilisé pour augmenter les profits d'une
minorité le ministre bruno le maire
avait déjà demandé visiblement sans
grand succès à ces grandes entreprises
de ne pas verser de dividendes durant la
crise nous pensons encore une fois de
façon assez minimaliste me semble-t-il
qu'il faudrait que ces entreprises qui
ont versé des revenus distribués lors du
dernier exercice clos soit exclu du
bénéfice des réductions de cotisations
prévues par le présent article je vous
remercie merci à vis de la commission le
rapporteur oui enfin simplement eu
madame apourceau poly moi j'ai relu
votre amendement et je suis désolé dans
votre amant
[Musique]
j'ai relu votre amendement est dans
votre amendement ou si vous les gars
toutes les entreprises et je suis suis
désolé mais du coup cet amendement
priverait effectivement les personnes
qui travaillent dans les petites
entreprises puisque si effectivement je
rappelle que dividendes et rémunération
personnelle des dirigeants dans les
petites entreprises c'est exactement la
même logique donc c'est un avis
défavorable ce qu'ils auraient un effet
contraire je pense est ce que vous
recherchez
gouvernement même avis
alors le 155 deux avis négatifs qui est
pour
et qui est contre
il est rejeté le 121 madame poncet mange
merci monsieur président cet amendement
vise à conditionner le bénéfice des
exonérations fiscales et sociales des
grandes entreprises de plus de 1000
salariés à des objectifs de transition
écologique et où l'égalité salariale
entre les femmes et les hommes
rappelons le ce dispositif de primes
porte le risque de substitution aux
augmentations parrain 2 pérenne de
salaire il convient donc au moins dont
conditionné l'octroi pour les
entreprises bénéficiaires de ces
exonérations sociales et fiscales qui
représentent un effort pour les finances
publiques de plusieurs milliards il est
quand même normal que la contrepartie ce
toit de prendre leur juste part de
responsabilité face à l'urgence
climatique est aussi sociale et
sanitaire afin de respecter nos
engagements climatiques les sociétés
françaises doivent accélérer leur
transformation dans le but d'être plus
résiliente au regard des risques
environnementaux
cet amendement entend favoriser leur
transition rapide vers une économie bas
carbone les entreprises doivent
également prendre leur part et respecter
les engagements en matière de maintien
de l'emploi et d'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes cet amendement tend
à conditionner le bénéfice des
exonérations donc aux entreprises qui
est vrai à diminuer les écarts de
rémunération entre les femmes et les
hommes pour rappel dans le secteur privé
en 2017 les femmes gagnent en moyenne 28
5 % de moins que les hommes et corrigée
du temps du travail mais c'est pas tout
à fait juste puisque le travail à temps
partiel et subi et subit par les femmes
mai corrigeait de ceux du temps de
travail et à poste équivalent bon
l'écart demeure quand même à 5,3 pour
cent donc voilà une conditionnalité tan
tan point sur le plan écologique que sur
plan social qui permettrait d'avancer
plus vite merci merci à vis de la
commission à la reporter comme l'avait
dit madame pense m en jeu c'est
effectivement une complexité de plus
puisque ont effectivement à 38 dans les
entreprises de plus de 1000 salariés des
dispositions des critères
environnementaux et sociaux vraiment le
principe de cette prime et et tout le
monde nous le dit c'est qu'elle est
simple opérationnel tentant de lui
conserver ce caractère longtemps donc un
avis défavorable gouvernement monsieur
le ministre mais ma vie je me revois le
121 avec deux avis négatifs qui est pour
et qui est contre
il est rejeté
le 243 2 246 monsieur lagourgue de 243
d'abord oui cet article
l'usiné à gaz qui va être la source de
nombreux redressement sociaux il est
donc logiquement proposé qu'en cas de
redressement le cotisant puisse saisir
le comité d abus de droit
la commission madame la rapporteure
alors c'est un amendement qui vise à une
information du quotidien de la
possibilité de saisir le comité d abus
de droit c'est un joli mot j'ai trouvé
en cas de redressement lié à la
distribution de la prime alors là c'est
intéressant de savoir monsieur le
ministre s'il ya eu beaucoup de de
contrôle des urssaf sur cette prime et
qu'est ce que ça a donné très
honnêtement il ne semble pas que créer
un comité ad-hoc pour cette prime soit
effectivement de nature à simplifier les
choses dans notre administration donc
c'est un avis défavorable à vis du
gouvernement
c'est un avis défavorable pour les mêmes
raisons et en réponse c'est madame la
rapporteure de nombreux contrôles ont eu
lieu sur les modalités de versement de
la prime est rapport à d'autres
dispositifs le taux de dossiers
litigieux soit parce que le règlement
n'était pas respectée soit parce qu'il y
avait une volonté caractérisée de fraude
est extrêmement bas donc nous ne
considérons pas utile de crimes comme un
comité spécifique supplémentaire donc
défavorable retrait
il est maintenant monsieur lagourgue
il est maintenu le 243
il est maintenue donc je le mets aux
voies avant que vous défendiez le 246 2
243 deux avis défavorables qui est pour
et qui est contre
il est rejeté vous pouvez défendre le
246 monsieur laâyoune l'article 1 créant
un système complexe pour les cotisants
compte quant au traitement social il
risque d'être la source nombreux
redressement sociaux le présent
amendement prévoit qu'en cas de
redressement de cotisants puisse
exprimer physiquement devant la
commission de recours amiable s'il en
est mais le souhait
merci à vis de la commission je pense
que lille sera répondu sur le sujet je
trouve que les choses fonctionnent
plutôt bien puisque effectivement il ya
déjà eu des contrôles qui sont pas
exorbitants par rapport à ce qui a pu
exister donc c'est plutôt un avis
défavorable a aussi la commission
gouvernement même avis il est maintenu
il est maintenu à l'est le 246 avec deux
avis défavorables qui et pour
qui compte
il est rejeté je vais mettre aux voix
l'ensemble de l'article 1 j'ai quelques
explications de vote monsieur lemoine je
vous en prie
le président effectivement le groupe r
des pays votre à certains cet article y
compris avec des amodiations auquel nous
avons pas toujours souscrit mais lorsque
j'entends le débat peut être rappeler
quelque chose nous ne posons pas la
prime aux salaires et nous agissons
aussi pour les salaires et notamment au
niveau du smic qui était proposée juste
avant l'article 1er est bien par
certains de monter le smic à 1500 euros
net je rappelle que le smic avec la
prime d'activité ca s'élève à 1400 75
euros nets on est donc à symptô tic si
je puis dire à ses 1500 euros net il
fallait le rappeler et lorsque j'entends
sur certains bancs le fait que la prime
serait ne serait pas satisfaisante parce
qu'elle ne toucherait que 16% des
salariés 5 millions de personnes je
rappelle qu'au niveau du smic y à deux
millions de personnes donc voilà
certains proposent de 7,2 d'apporter une
amélioration car ces deux millions de
personnes nous nous faisons bien sûr
mais nous considérons que la prime ne
doit pas s'opposer à cela -la prime je
rappelle que non seulement ces cinq
millions de personnes mais quelque part
à travers elle c'est 5 millions de
foyers ces 9 milliards d'euros depuis le
début de l'institution de ce dispositif
en 2019 qui ont été ainsi distribués et
je me fie aux rapports de la rapporteure
puis ça je lis en page 11 qu' un tiers
des salariés éligibles en ont bénéficié
un tiers autant dire que c'est assez
significatif
j'ai le souvenir dans cet hémicycle non
pas à cette place mais plutôt sur le
côté des débats qui ont eu cours en 2006
lorsque serge dassault isabelle debré à
l'époque rapportait le projet de loi sur
la participation mais écoutez que
reste-t-il du dividende du travail créée
à l'époque eh ben je trouve je trouve
que avoir une prime qui en trois ans
s'est installé dans un tiers des
salariés éligibles et bien comme on le
dirait dans un grand film je crois que
on a donné sa chance au produit et qu'il
faut continuer c'est pourquoi nous
voterons avec ardeur cet article 1er eh
bien je ne sais pas quelle est la
différence d'un vote avec ardeur et dans
votre tout court mais il ya aucun
problème madame lui ben
oui moi je voudrais d'abord ce que je
viens d'entendre une comparaison que je
trouve un petit peu hasardeuse rajouter
la prime d'activité au smic pour dire
que finalement on est quasiment à 1500
euros je rappellerai que la prime
d'activité porte bien mal son nom parce
qu'il ne s'agit pas d'une prime même si
elle s'appelle comme ça il s'agit d'une
allocation qui est versée par la
solidarité nationale et non pas par les
employeurs donc ça n'a rien à voir avec
le salaire et avec l'augmentation du
smic nous nous voterons contre nous
voterons contre
ces primes non pas que nous soyons
opposé à ce que des salariés perçoivent
des primes mais nous considérons que
dans cette période d'inflation qui
risque de s'inscrire durablement dans le
temps ça ne peut pas être la réponse à
eau à l'amélioration à la question de
l'amélioration du pouvoir d'achat nous
considérons enfin c'est pas nous
considérons les chiffres le disent tous
les salariés bien loin s'en faut
n'auront pas accès à ces versements de
primes et donc on ne peut pas dire que
ce projet de loi après ce vote de primes
répondra aux besoins d'augmentation du
pouvoir d'achat de tous les salariés de
ce pays voilà nous avons la volonté de
répondre à la question du pouvoir
d'achat et pour cela il n'y a qu'un seul
moyen utilisable c'est le moyen du
salaire que vous ne vouliez ou non alors
j'entends ici et là des voix qui
s'élèvent pour dire bon d'accord les
primes on aurait préféré autre chose
mais on va faire avec c'est mieux que
rien le problème c'est qu'à force de
nous contenter du mieux que rien on
finit par avoir à rien et toujours pour
les mêmes
c'est madame la présidente mme rossignol
merci monsieur le président je voudrais
aborder un angle de vue qui est celui de
l'impact de cette prime sur l'égalité
professionnelle entre les femmes et les
hommes et en particulier sur les
rémunérations des femmes
nous savons parce que ça a été étudiée
depuis plusieurs années que tout
dispositif neutre en termes d'impact sur
les femmes et les hommes est en réalité
un dispositif qui de plus souvent
accroît les inégalités qui sont au
départ celle du dispositif en l'espèce
les inégalités salariales entre les âmes
et les hommes et femmes sont connus et
identifiés
comment cette prime était répartie entre
les femmes et les hommes alors c'est pas
dans l'étude d'impact que j'ai trouvé la
réponse je vous rassure il n'y a rien
l'indigence de l'étude d'impact est
telle que ce sujet n'a même pas été
abordée or en matière de politique
publique il serait bon que nous en
passion à cette étude genres et des
disposer des politiques publiques je
vais vous simplement vous dire qu'elles
sont lestés les huit secteurs qui ont le
plus bénéficié de la prime précédente
services financiers assurances commerce
matériels de transport bien équipements
industriels cokéfaction raffinage
énergie eau déchets activités
scientifiques et techniques et
construction sur ces huit secteurs les
femmes ne se compose que 30% des
salariés de ces secteurs donc je
n'extrapole pas j'en déduis qu'à coup
sûr les hommes salariés ont davantage
bénéficier de cette prime et
bénéficieront demain encore davantage de
cette prime parce que le des plug
l'augmentation du plafond à 3 smic ne
changera rien à la répartition traduit
bénéficiaire est donc ce dispositif de
la prime est un dispositif qui accroît
les inégalités professionnelles entre
les femmes et les hommes c'est une
raison supplémentaire de voter contre
merci feu mais aux voies et merci de
bien levé la main je mets aux voix
l'article 1 qui est pour
merci qui est contre
il est adopté
après l'article 1er le 317 madame poncet
mange
merci monsieur le président eh bien je
vais être accord avec l'intervention
précédentes parce que cet amendement de
mme elhady vogel demande au gouvernement
la remise d'un rapport et j'espère qu'il
sera voté